[Musique]
Maxime Ren bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh oui, je m'appelle Maxime Renaï, j'ai
41 ans, je vis entre l'Évoug et Beson.
Euh j'ai travaillé pendant 5 ans de 2007
à 2010 12 pardon euh dans la finance
offshore dans les paradis fiscaux à Jarz
au Luxembourg et pendant la même période
j'ai renseigné la DGSE donc les services
secrets français de de ce qui se passait
de ce que je voyais euh dans ces paradis
fiscaux. Depuis 2012, j'aide des
associations, les groupes de salariés
euh quand ils font des actions
juridiques contre les actionnaires, des
fonds d'investissement,
les patrons qui font des des tournements
de fond, abus de bien sociaux et cetera.
Et en 2019, là il y a un peu plus d'un
an, j'ai sorti un livre qui s'appelle Là
où est l'argent qui est mon témoignage
justement de de mon passage dans la
finance et au service de de enfin et et
mon travail mon partenariat je dirais
avec la DGSE, enfin le travail qui a été
fourni avec la DGSE.
Euh et tu m'avais vous m'aviez invité à
ce moment-là. Donc je crois en
septembre, ça doit faire 8 9 mois que
voilà.
Donc on va on va pas refaire l'interview
d' 9 mois, mais on va quand même vous te
reposer des des questions concernant ça.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a qui t'a poussé
à à devenir un renégat de la DGS ?
un renegga. Euh bah disons c'est ce que
je disais un petit peu dans le livre ou
ou dans l'interview à l'époque, c'était
euh bon je me vois pas comme un renégat
mais disons
renég dans le bon sens du terme
OK. Disons qu'il y avait une frustration
pour moi de voir que les informations
que je donnais étaient à mon sens mal
utilisées ou pas assez utilisé et aussi
de je comprenais que mes informations
allaient pourah les les les puissances
fortes les multinationales et pas pour
les citoyens et pour le l'état la nation
en tant que telle. Donc cette
frustration m'a amené à à à me dire bon
il faut que tu prennes une décision.
Est-ce que tu continues dans la finance
en envoyant des informations de façon
euh euh enfin de façon très régulière à
la DGSE, à tes différents officiers
traitants que tu voilà que tu vois où
est-ce que bah tu reviens au pays et tu
mets ton expertise que tu as acquise au
service directement de de des salariés,
des des citoyens. Donc c'est ce que j'ai
décidé de faire. Euh donc oui, dans ce
sens-là, si tu veux, je suis je suis un
renégat effectivement.
Alors, on va faire attention aujourd'hui
comme on est en direct, pas de
diffamation, que des choses sourcées,
que des choses prouvées et tout ce que
tu diras ne sera imputable qu'à toi et
peut-être à moi
en droit à toi mais aussi mais voilà
mais je vais faire très attention, il y
a pas de problème.
Et donc on fait vous, tu fais très
attention. Je vais te poser une
question.
Tu as tes anciens collègues de travail
que ce soit dans la finance ou que ce
soit la DGSE, il te considère comment
maintenant ? Alors euh disons dans la
finance euh
euh disons que j'ai euh comment est-ce
que je pourrais dire ? Il y a ceux qui
déjà ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il y a
eu avant le Covid et après le Covid. Euh
il faut savoir que avant le Covid euh
avec la sortie du livre notamment les
anciens
les anciennes personnes qui étaient qui
travaillaient avec moi, les
connaissances, les copains et copines
amies, quand ils ont vu le livre sortir,
ils sont dit "Bon, on savait que Max
était un peu excentrique, bon voilà, on
s'était pas trompé.
Voilà, il sort le bouquin. Voilà. Euh
il faut savoir qu'il y a moi, il y a
quelques années, les il y a beaucoup de
gens de la finance, quand je leur disais
qu'un jour j'allais me tirer, j'allais
retourner en France, il me prenaient
pour un fou. Je leur disais qu'on allait
un jour avoir une crise financière,
politique et cetera. Il me prenait pour
un fou. Maintenant euh
maintenant c'est la normalité pour pas
dire la banalité de de dire ces
choses-là.
C'est en quelle année ça ? Ça c'était en
2010 quand quand je disais que je
j'allais euh à mes collègues que
j'allais me tirer. Euh il rigolait, il
me disait "Ah, Max, tu es tu es tu es tu
es bargeot quoi ?" Euh voilà, c'était le
le douingue un petit peu. Et puis de
douingue tout d'un coup, mais moi
j'étais pas stressé si tu veux, c'était
juste, je me disais bon, il va avoir des
il va forcément avoir des des problèmes
importants dans les années à venir en
terme de gouvernance, en terme de de de
problèmes financiers et cetera.
Et euh et là maintenant, ce sont ces
gens-là qui sont extrêmement stressés.
J'en ai eu pas mal qui m'ont d'ailleurs
contacté pendant le Covid euh en me
disant "Ouais, tu avais raison tout ça,
on l'avait pas vu. Ouais, il faudrait
qu'on s'achète une maison au vert,
faudrait qu'on fasse c, faudrait qu'on
fasse ça, qu'est-ce que tu nous
conseilles ?" Tout ça. Donc voilà, il y
a un peu entre guillemets, je veux pas
dire un retour de bâton parce que je
voilà, c'est pas un retour de bâton mais
disons euh c'est marrant de voir qu'and
assez peu de temps sur 8 ans on passe de
douingue à tout d'un coup. Bon, quelque
chose absolument banal.
Et en terme de d'anciens collègues de du
des des services ?
Ah, aucun aucun contact. J'ai des j'ai
des retours de la de par différentes
personnes journalistes spécialisés ou
différentes autres sources ou contacts
que j'ai. Je sais ce que pense la DGSE
de la sortie du livre. Il y a plusieurs
personnes, voilà, très sérieuses qui
m'ont filé. Je sais qu'ils sont pas
contents au plus haut niveau de la
sortie de ce livre.
Pourquoi ? Euh pourquoi euh parce que ça
fait h pourquoi euh en en tout cas je
sais sans rentrer dans le détail parce
que tu as dit qu'il fallait faire
attention euh disons que je sais que
aussi ils ont voulu ménager aussi toutes
les personnes qui travaillent pour eux
euh bénévolement ou avec rémunération et
qui voudraient pas tout d'un coup me
faire une pub et aussi euh euh
créer d'autres renégas
d'autres renégats et donner trop
d'importance au livre et à mon action Et
donc si tu vois faire leur but c'est
faire profil bas là-dessus c'est c'est
une pratique totalement commune de ce
que font les angloaxons. C'est profil
bas banc on parle pas. Voilà c'est il y
a pas de souci. Moi je je reste à leur
disposition évidemment.
Est-ce que tu penses que tu es écouté ?
Oui ça arrive sans doute. Oui oui sans
aucun doute. Oui. Oui.
Pour quel motif ?
Sur des investigations là
principalement. Ben en fait, bon là, je
pense qu'on va sûrement, tu m'as invité
sûrement pour parler de d'une
Tuen sais rien.
J'en sais rien du tout. Ouais,
j'en sais absolument rien. Tu as raison.
Mais euh
donc oui, j'ai sorti
une série d'investigations là, mais euh
attends, j'ai perdu le fil déjà. Euh
attends, excuse, c'était
Vous parlait de quoi ?
Toi aussi tu as perdu le fil ? Non non,
je te laisse à la rame.
Tu me laisses à la rame. Euh,
l' viis de la DGSE sur ton bouquin,
est-ce que tu te sens écouté ?
Ah oui, ah oui, écoutez. Oui, vis-à-vis
des des investigations que je je mène en
ce moment en donc je mène principalement
pour la web télé média pour laquelle je
travaille qui est dirigé par Denis
Robert. Euh donc, je travaille avec eux
depuis juillet, je crois. De
combien combien il paye ?
Combien il me paye ? Bah, en fait c'est
à la facture, c'est uniquement par
investigation qui qui sortent. Euh donc
bah sur sachant que en fait je suis pas
pigiste, je suis pas j'ai pas de CDI,
j'ai pas de CDD, je suis pas pigiste,
c'est à la facture et là-dessus moi je
paye donc mes cotisations. Donc une fois
que j'ai payé mes cotisations, les
premières investigations
en premières investigations par exemple
Brisol qui que j'ai sorti après de
passer ici c'était payé 2000 bruts. Donc
ça me fait je sais pas
net
un peu plus. Non non un peu plus.
Euh voilà,
par rapport aux écoutes, pourquoi être
écouté ? Pourquoi tu penses que tu es
écouté ? Bah disons qu'il y a certains
sujets alors peut-être pas sur Brisol ou
BFM TV que j'ai sorti mais par exemple
sur tu vois je travaille sur Génal
électrique Bfort
je travaille sur
je travaille sur Proctor et Gumble
France je travaille sur qu'est-ce que
c'est je travaille sur des sujets ou
avec des multinationales avec des
interaméricains. Alors quand il y a des
écoutes, je veux pas pas for c'est pas
forcément des écoutes françaises hein.
Je suis en contact avec
j'ai des amis qui sont en fait aussi
c'est peut-être aussi les les le réseau
d'amis que j'ai qui peut prêter aux
écoute. Je suis avec ami avec des gens
très différents, avec des gens des
gilets jaunes emblématiques à Besançon
par exemple avec des gens qui mènent des
combats une Zade à Besançon. Donc moi je
suis dans dans je suis pour cette zade à
Besenançon dans une ville qui est écolo
si tu veux. Donc tu vois, on va bétonner
prochainement 34 hectares d'un poumon
vert à Besançon qui était qui est
superbe qui un écrain vert qui était
protégé. Et on a une messe qui euh qui
dit "Bon, on va bétonner" qui était déjà
dans l'ancien conseil municipal avec
l'ancien maire PS qui était devenu qui
avait retourné Casac qui est devenu PS
et bon donc moi je suis un peu dans des
milieux très différents avec des
lanceurs d'alerte. Donc voilà, c'est des
gens qui qui sortent des informations
des multinationales ou forcément que tu
ça ça dérange les forces vives, on va
dire.
Donc là les forces vives, tu penses être
écouté par la DCI, mais tu disais par
des puissances étrangères. Qu'est-ce que
ça fait de se faire écouter en tant que
français sur le sol français avec un
téléphone français par une puissance
étrangère en étant ancien de la ancien
de la DGS ?
Alors non, là je te con, je suis pas un
ancien de la DGSE.
Si tu as collaboré avec eux, tu es une
un honorable contributeur, un un
donc un agent
non un un ancien DGSE, c'estàdire un
fonctionnaire de la DGSE. Moi, j'ai
jamais été fonctionnaire. J'ai
D'accord. Donc, tu étais juste agent.
Voilà, c'est agent. Agent pour la DGE
mais pas fonctionnaire.
D'accord. personne pour moi. Oui. Oui.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait de se sentir
écouté par une puissance étrangère ?
Rien du tout franchement.
Ni chaud ni frérot. Enfin, je veux dire
ça ça change absolument rien dans ma
façon de procéder, d'investiguer, de
rencontrer les gens. Franchement, je je
m'en moque en fait. On va revenir un peu
sur ton passé un peu plus tard. Je vais
je vais je vais te poser une question.
Le Covid-19 ou
en tant qu'ancienne source de la DGSE,
est-ce que tu t'es projeté ? Est-ce que
tu t'es imaginé être une source de
terrain en Chine de la DGSE ?
Ah non, jamais.
Est-ce qu'on peut essayer de se se
mettre sur le terrain ? Je suis ton
officier traitant.
Oui.
Tu t'actives tout seul parce que tu es
loin d'être bête. Tu vois des trucs se
passer. Tu me fais remonter quel type
d'information ? Je dirais le 1er
janvier.
H le 1er janvier. Là tu me prends Ouais.
Tu très bonne question. Euh
tu procéderaiis comment ?
Sur place. Tu es sur place. Tu
travailles dans la tech.
Ça fait 3 4 ans que tu es sur place. Ta
copine est chinoise ou ta copine n'est
pas chinoise ou tu es sans ta copine.
Comment tu procéderais pour me faire
remonter de l'information de terrain
brut au départ et peut-être comme tu es
un peu plus intelligent peut-être
interpréter ? Alors, tu me flattes
beaucoup. Déjà, moi, je suis quelqu'un
de très simple. Déjà, j'ai moi j'ai le
problème de faire des enquêtes sur le
long terme. Donc déjà, j'aurai un
problème d'ajustement parce que moi je
quand je fais des enquêtes, ça dure des
mois, voire plus que ça. Donc là, vu la
rapidité avec le virus, je serais pris
de cours,
même sur place.
Même sur place. Euh là, tu me poses
vraiment une colle et en plus mon autre
donc déjà je travaille sur le long terme
et ensuite ma spécialité c'est vraiment
tout ce qui est plus économique. Donc
voilà euh en étant sur place, je dirais
je ferai je pense ce qui a été fait. Je
regarderai peut-être déjà le funérarium.
J'irai faire du des tours du côté des
des funéarium pour voir au niveau de la
cadence. Euh, j'irai voir au niveau euh
en fait, j'essaierai de sortir quand
c'est interdit parce que je pourrais pas
m'en empêcher pour voir ce qui se passe
dans la rue. Euh,
est-ce que j'aurais eu le temps de
mettre un réseau en place d'amis capable
de collecter des informations ? J'aurais
tendance à dire oui, c'est dans ma
nature. Donc je pense que j'aurais déjà
des des amis et sans doute des process
en place pour pour pour avoir des des
informations importantes.
Euh mais la collègue d'information, mais
tu le sais bien mieux que moi, je veux
dire, c'est euh
Pourquoi je le sais mieux que toi ?
disons, c'est déjà avoir un réseau
d'amis, enfin à mon sens, euh être à
l'écoute euh et puis aussi avoir
conscience de de ces failles et de ces
Donc moi, je te dis moi ma faille c'est
de travailler sur le long si tu le long
cours.
Donc oui, pour résumer, regarder tout ce
qui est morbidité, cimetière,
euh évidemment couper tout ce qui est
radio, information, internet pour ne
vraiment pas être influencé et activer
les les amis et puis oui, faire des
choses interdites, c'estàdire sortir
dans la rue, voir ce qui se passe le
soir, faire des tours dans enfin, il
faut prendre le le la température sur
place quoi en fait
avec ou sans téléphone les petites
sorties.
Ah bah sans téléphone.
Pourquoi ?
Bah enfin, je veux dire c'est de enfah
tout le monde sait qu'avec le téléphone
il y a un risque de enfin il y a plus
qu'un risque que surtout en Chine tu vas
être suivi même pas la trace quoi. Donc
non c'est sûr. Puis je pense que
d'ailleurs il faut toute une stratégie
pour sortir même sans téléphone vu que
tout est surveillé avec des caméras
et avec des milices.
Et avec des milices.
Euh donc oui, il y a il y a toute une
stratégie donc je pourrais pas définir
comme ça à réfléchir. Moi c'est un cas
d'écool qui m'intéresserait mais je
pense qu'il me faudrait quelques jours
pour réfléchir laisser un fusé. Je
commencerai intuitivement à marquer des
idées. En fait, ça prendrait quelques
idées avant de
marquer.
Oui. Non, mais enfin, excuse-moi, disons
à réfléchir à quelques idées. Oui. Pas à
marquer, puis après les coller et puis à
les mettre sur sur internet. Mais non.
Alors, imagine-toi, tu te fais visiter
par exemple quand tu vas faire tes
courses au bout de 2 jours parce que tu
as le droit de sortir que tous les deux
jours pour faire tes courses. Tu reviens
chez toi, tu te fais visiter, ton vernis
à ongle sur les vis, il a été sauté, des
trucs ont été déplacés chez toi.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Moi moi déjà je pars du principe que de
toute façon tout ce que je enfin tu vois
sans être du tout parano je pars du
principe que tout ce que je fais peut
être vu, lu, écouté ou ou entendu si tu
veux. à former pour ça.
Non, mais je c'est juste par principe et
voilà, par expérience, je sais que euh
c'est tellement facile avec les les les
moyens étatiques même des
multinationales de de d'aller sur ton
ordinateur comme ça, sur ton téléphone
comme ça, de te mettre une puce GPS sous
ta voiture, d'avoir des gens qui te
suivent. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est
c'est basique. Euh non, je pense j'en
reviendrai toujours moi un peu à à à mes
C'est basique ou ils ont pas les bases
là, je sais pas. En tout cas, moi je
reviendrai plutôt à mes à mes basiques à
moi, c'est-à-dire de passer pour l'idiot
de service et le mec qui comprend pas
trop ce qui se passe et qui me balade un
peu dans la rue. C'est la c'est la
meilleure façon de faire et pour
l'instant ça a toujours plutôt pas trop
mal marché.
Maintenant, tu es un peu cramé quand
même.
Non, j'ai toujours un peu une tête un
petit peu tu sais de d'uri, tu sais.
Donc ça ça marche encore un petit peu.
Bah
ça marche pas. Tuas pas loin d'avoir une
tête d'uria.
Tu as le regard vif et le poil soyeux.
Revenons à nos moutons. Le Covid. Est-ce
que tu penses que la DGSE a fait son taf
pour tenir au courant notre état, notre
ministère de la santé ? Est-ce que tu
penses que ils ont joué correctement
leur rôle de faire collecter de
l'information pour que l'État ne soit
pas dépourvu, borgne ou aveugle
et manchaud ? Alors moi je déjà je euh
sur le Covid et déjà je me permets pas
de juger la DGSE, je parce que je sais
que les
les officiers traitant euh que j'ai
rencontré sur les 5 années étaient
vraiment euh exceptionnels. C'était des
gens euh qui avaient une culture
générale incroyable, des gens qui
étaient patriotes euh qui aimai
patriotes ou nationalistes Non non,
patriote vraiment au sens large. J'ai
j'ai jamais rencontré à mon sens de de
gens d'extrême droite ou nationalistes.
En tout cas, j'ai pas ressenti. Non non,
c'était des gens vraiment admirables.
Donc je suis pas là pour les juger. Ça
sert à rien de les enfoncer. Si on
regarde
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi tu trouves qu'ils
s'enfoncent tout seul comme des grands ?
Non non, c'est pas ce que je veux dire.
Mais quand on regarde en tout cas au
niveau de l'État, il se peut très bien
qu'ils aient donné une très bonne
information
pas suivie par les politiques.
Pas suivie par les politiques, ce qui
est enfin, je veux dire même pas un
classique quoi. Je veux dire, donc il y
a de fortes chances qu'ils aient donné
et et même pire peut-être même si tu
regardes bien que il y a des agents et
des officiers traités en Chine qui ont
fait un excellent boulot et que même le
niveau intermédiaire alors je pas non
plus enfoncer les big boss de la DGSE
mais n'est pas relayé suffisamment ou
qui tu sais enfin tu le sais mieux que
moi
parce que tu as tout un bon réseau. Il y
a des guerres d'ego au niveau de de à la
tête de de l'ego aussi tue la tue
l'intelligence évidemment. Donc il se
peut très bien que même les informations
n même pas pu aller au
à la tête de l'État sans vouloir excuser
la tête de l'État parce que voilà parce
que je suis pas un grand fan des gens
qui sont la tête de l'État évidemment.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils sont prétentieux et qu'ils
ont ils ont enfin je veux dire tout le
monde s'accorde pour dire qu'ils ont on
peut même pas dire qu'ils ont mal géré
le Covid. C'est un désastre quoi. C'est
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé dans
les épades, quand on voit qu' nous en
tant que puissance, enfin puissance, bon
c'est un mot qui veut tout dit rien dire
mais tout en tant que pays agréable à
vivre, intelligent,
on était même plus capable de de
produire des bouts de tissu pour nous
protéger. Euh
Macron, il a encore la chance d'être
d'être chez lui alors qu'il est enfin je
veux dire les gens sont suffisamment
résilient et il peut les remercier
résilient résilient ou ou impuissant.
Alors impuissant, moi ma grande théorie
depuis 10 ans, c'est enfin grande
théorie c'est pour rigoler que je dis
ça, hein. C'est tant que le système
financier tourne, les gens ne ne
remettront pas le système en place. En
tout cas, même si
en question, excuse-moi, même si euh je
suis
très agréablement surpris et heureux de
voir que depuis 10 ans vraiment il y a
une accélération qui a un pourcentage de
la population qui grandit de jour en
jour, quelses que soient les origines,
les les comment dire les les idéos
politiques ou non politiques qui qui qui
sont de plus en plus conscients de ce
qui se passe en terme d'écologie, qu'on
va droit dans le mur, en terme politique
qu'on va droit dans le mur et en terme
financier.
Donc toutes ces questions là, ça
existait pas quasiment il y a 10 ans.
Les gens, je dis, je me répète, mais il
y a 10 ans, quand je sortais des
banalités sur le les problèmes qui qui
arrivent maintenant, les gens nous
prenaient pour pour quand je dis nous,
mon frère et moi nous prenaient pour des
fous. Il y a 5 ans, clair
du temps. Euh,
ça fait mal ?
Non, non, non, non, pas du tout. Tu as
pas d'ego ?
Bah comme comme tout le monde, mais
j'essaie de je crois que ma mission moi
c'est justement de dans ma vie c'est de
de mettre mon ego de côté, de le
diminuer, de le malaxer pour parce que
l'ego de toute façon n'amène que de la
souffrance et de la négativité. Donc
c'est un bon maître si tu veux pour
connaître ces ses limites, mais faut
savoir aussi le le mettre de côté et le
diminuer.
Le polir
le polir. Exactement.
Et là dernièrement, j'ai lu euh je me
suis mis lire quelques bouquins avec le
confinement, mais pas que par exemple
sur Marc Orel Solilock et tout ça. Et
bon, maintenant il y a plus des livres
de développement personnel mais je veux
dire quand tu vois qu'il y a déjà 2000
ans, tu avais enfin tout est dit déjà il
y a 2000 ans quoi.
Donc c'est sûr, moi quand j'avais 20
ans, je comprenais pas forcément le
genre de livre mais maintenant à
postéran je comprends exactement ce
qu'il voulait dire quoi. Quel que soient
les actions, ce qu'on vit, quels que
soient les drames, queles que soient les
horreurs ou les gens difficiles qu'on
qu'on rencontre,
on se doit rester d'avoir un calme
intérieur et de pas être dépendant des
choses extérieures.
Est-ce que tu penses que tu as été
contacté en partie par la DGSE parce que
tu sentais que la crise venait et que
eux avaient besoin de de personnes
sensibles sur ce type de sujet capable
de leur faire remonter de l'information
de terrain ? Attends, excuse-moi, j'ai
j'ai pas bien entendu.
C'est normal, c'est le masque.
Ouais.
Est-ce que tu penses que tu as été
contacté par la DGSE pour devenir une
source parce qu'ils avaient fait ton
péri avant, ils avaient vu que tu avais
quand même senti que la crise avançait ?
Non non
non.
Ah non non pas du tout. C'est moi qui
les ont contacté. C'est moi qui les a
contacté.
Non non je me continue.
Ah ou non c'est
tu es arrivé tu es arrivé ? Tu dit
bonjour je travaille là serait bien pour
vous ? Non, en fait c'est en donc comme
je je le dis dans mon livre là où
l'argent en fait euh donc je suis rentré
dans la finance vraiment entre
guillemets par hasard euh comme je le
dis euh parce que maintenant je donne
des petites conférences auprès de
syndicat ou de gens qui qui souhaitent
que je parle du
Tu es payé pour tes conférences ?
Oui euh certaines oui, d'autres non.
Combien ? Par exemple, la conférence
chez mes amis Force Ouvrière de
Besançon, j'étais payé 250 € et ils ont
vraiment voulu me rémunérer. Ils sont
enfin voilà, j'étais gêné mais ils ont
vraiment voilà, ils ont été super clean.
J'ai eu un bon repas avec eux enfin sont
vraiment géniaux et voilà, je développe
aussi au niveau local, je développe
vraiment à Besançon
des synergies avec les gilets jaunes,
avec des syndicats type force ouvrière,
avec
extinction rébellion. Voilà.
Est-ce que Est-ce que Est-ce que tu
pourrais nous dire ce que tu votes ?
Ah moi ce que je vote Oui, après je peux
te le dire mais c'est je je suis
catalogué si tu veux euh gauche radical.
Euh je pour amis bah par exemple on
pourra peut-être en parler tout à
l'heure quand on parlera, si tu le
souhaites, des de l'investigation que
j'ai sortie. Je suis ami avec le
secrétaire général du PCF Fabien
Roussel. Je suis ami avec Hugo Bernal
ici qui est député de la France
insoumise. J'ai soutenu une liste France
insoumise avec des des des
gens qui étaient pas dans le mouvement
pour le pour l'élection municipale de
Besançon. Après voilà, je suis plutôt de
gauche mais je suis pas non plus si tu
veux je suis capable de parler avec les
gens de tous les partis. C'est pas je
suis pas enfermé au niveau idéologique
mais c'est ma mouvance. Oui, c'est
voilà.
Revenons. Donc tu es arrivé, tuas tu as
toqué, tu as appelé la DGSE, tu es venu
à leur porte, tu as dit quoi ? dit
alors déjà pour un petit peu dans dans
le passé euh mais ça je crois que j'en
avais parlé déjà dans l'interview en
gros au niveau de la culture dans dans
ma famille de mon grand-père paternel et
de mon père, il y avait déjà la culture
de
de comment dire euh de la clandestinité
déjà avec mon grand-père qui a été donc
résistant à 20 ans en 1940
et ensuite avec mon père qui était dans
un parti d'extrême gauche interdit par
Timis pendant une dizaine d'années avec
un faux prénom une fois l'identité et
cetera. Donc pour moi, si tu veux, c'est
ces personnes qui ont été mes modèles,
c'était on sert les autres et on le fait
gratuitement avec plaisir et honneur.
Donc si tu veux, voilà, j'ai déjà été
programmé d'une certaine façon, même si
après le but de notre vie tout à chacun,
c'est aussi de se déprogrammer de de ce
qui nous a été
de donné à la naissance. Et donc c'est
avec ces bases là et aussi le désir
depuis que je suis enfant de de faire
des choses un peu entre guillemets
fantases, c'est-à-dire de je voulais
être espion, je voulais et tu as
toujours une option à un moment donné la
vie elle touvre toujours une porte, elle
te donne toujours une opportunité et euh
bon je vais faire court tout tout ça
c'est écrit dans le livre mais disons à
un moment donné quand en fait j'étais
parti en Angleterre pour apprendre
l'anglais ensuite il y a une copine
avocate qui me dit "Est-ce que tu veux
pas aller à Jersé paradis fiscale ? On a
besoin de quelqu'un qui parle français
dans un cabinet d'avocat. on va
t'apprendre ce que c'est que la finance.
Moi, je me suis dit super, je vais
peut-être pouvoir vivre ma vie de
d'aventurier si tu veux, même si euh tu
vois les comptes, les contrats, c'est
pas forcément une vie d'aventurier dans
l'absolu. Et dès que je suis arrivé dans
le Saint-Dess à Jersy, dans le plus gros
cabinet d'avocat, au bout de quelques
semaines, même si c'était très compliqué
de comprendre ce qui se passait, euh et
ben je me suis dit, il faut que je
contacte la DGSE. Pour moi, c'était je
pouvais enfin accomplir, tu vois, ce ce
rêve de de gamin, si tu veux. Si tu
avais été d'une puissance étrangère,
est-ce qu'ils ont fait une enquête de
proximité sur toi ?
Oui, ça je le sais. Oui. Sur sur ma
famille, sur combien de
génération ils sont montés ?
Euh alors je peux pas dire en tout cas
mon père c'est sûr, ma sœur et mon frère
certain. Il savaient combien ce que
j'avais sur mon compte en banque. Il
savait à l'époque la copine que j'avais
qui était anglaise. Euh il savait bah ce
qui était normal, je veux dire c'est la
moine des choses. Mais ça me dérangeait
pas. Des fois, il y a je sais qu'il y a
un officier traitant qui me chambre en
me disant tiens tu as ça sur ton compte
enfin je sais pas il y avait des deux
trois trucs comme ça quoi. Bon moi ça me
ça me faisait ça me fait rigoler quoi.
Voilà
c'est tout.
C'est tout.
Ils sont venus chez toi ?
Chez moi non jamais.
Comment tu sais ?
Ah oui bah bonne question. Non. Euh bah
disons avec l'informatique oui. Ils sont
donc venus chez moi dans l'absolu sans
doute. Et puis je ne sais pas
t'ont suivi.
Je peux
ils t'ont donné des fausses missions
pour savoir comment tu régissais ?
Non je pense pas. Non non non je pense
pas.
Est-ce que tu as d'autres puissances qui
ont essayé de t'approcher avant, pendant
et après ?
Après oui, après le premier Finkerview.
Lesquels ?
Ouais, je pense pas en parler disons. Il
y a deux pays. Ouais. euh
les Américains, les Russes, les
Javanais, la Tasmanie.
On va être respectueux de ces de de ces
deux pays. Enfin, il y en a un, je
respecte pas spécialement, mais disons
euh disons que le voilà je
ça a été voilà
comment ça s'est passé.
Ben moi, je suis curieux par nature si
tu veux. Il y a Si tu veux, on cherche à
me tamponner. J'essaie de voir pour
quelles sont les raisons si tu veux.
Tu mets tu mets le doigt dans le dans le
dans la confiture pour
dans la confiture pour goûter la
confiture ou pas ? Non, même pas. C'est
juste non pour pour voir
pour voir quelles sont les demandes en
fait et pourquoi pourquoi moi
du renseignement.
Bah oui, c'estàd tu collectes le c'est
je veux dire à partir du moment où il y
a un échange, tu collectes toujours de
l'information. Déjà savoir qui est cette
personne qui vient de nulle part
et qui qui te qui cherche à te
contacter, qui qui veut ton plus grand
bien et si et ça donc c'est intéressant.
Ça te permet aussi de voir les enjeux
des États étrangers. Ça permet aussi de
voir que parce que moi je suis un
moucheron si tu veux en terme de de
notoriété ou tout ce que tu veux ou de
Mais c'est intéressant de voir que tu as
certains pays qui ont une forme de ruse
en se disant "Ah tiens ce moucheron mais
peut-être que dans quelques années il
fera quelque chose de un peu plus
intéressant." Donc voilà, c'était
intéressant de voir ces deux profils.
Alors pour l'information c'était deux
femmes mais
et genre bien ou pas bien ?
Des des
c'était ton style ? Ah non, non, mais
attends euh non, quand je dis des
femmes, c'est pour rigoler. C'est une
parenthèse. Mais ce que je veux dire,
c'était non des personnes très
intelligentes, extrêmement
intelligentes. Vraiment, j'ai été euh
impressionné par euh euh
par leur façon de d'être et leur leur
leur intelligence. Oui.
Mais voilà, ça s'est arrêté. Euh une
fois que j'ai vu qui j'avais à faire, ça
pu se confirmer. Voilà, c'est au revoir.
Ciao.
Tu as pas essayé de les infiltrer ?
Non, non, non. J'ai déjà trop de travail
avec les investigations, j'ai pas le
temps.
Si la des GSE t'avais contacté pour les
infiltrer, tu aurais fait quoi ?
Bien sûr, je l'aurais fait.
Bah oui. Attends, j'aime mon pays,
évidemment.
Donc euh voilà, il y a quelques petites
histoires comme ça aussi. Euh bon, je du
coup si je y en a une, je sais pas si je
peux la dire. Euh
euh
si tu sais pas si tu
Je réfléchis, je réfléchis.
Allez. Euh j'espère que le copain va pas
trop m'en vouloir.
Euh je sais pas, je vois
pas de nom. Non non pas de nom, je vais
pas dire de nom.
Pas de source en danger hein.
D'accord. Bon disons qu'il y a un
ministère, on va résumer ça va être très
clair et très court. Un ministère et
c'est pas ministère des armées qui a dit
Ren il est ultra personat. Ça j'ai mon
sur un truc bien précis. Je j'étais
potentiellement invité
à à une grosse réunion avec voilà des
gros cadors et ça a été la réponse qui a
été donné quand mon nom était avancé par
les personnes qui souhaitaient m'inviter
avec des des gens de ce ministère. J'ai
trouvé ça marrant. J'ai trouvé ça
dommage en même temps parce que j'aurais
pu aussi leur filer des informations
importantes.
Tu es déçu ?
Non pas déçu. Je dis c'est c'est dommage
pour eux. Tant pis quoi. C'est avec 0 €
ils auraient pu avoir un maximum
d'information sur un sujet qui est
intéressant pour eux. Tant pis.
Et euh on va revenir on va revenir aux
questions internet. Euh
que pensent-il de l'affaire Alstom ? Une
question d'Aurélien, la première que je
vois passer sous les yeux d'ailleurs.
Excusez-moi, on va remonter un peu le
fil. Que penses-t-il de l'affaire Alstom
?
Alors Alstom, je je tu veux dire
l'affaire Pierucci et tout ça ? Moi je
je pense j'ai pas spécialement envie de
d'en parler parce que je pense que tu as
déjà super bien couvert le sujet avec
Pierroci avec Marlex Olivier Marlex
et Montebourg
et Monbourg effectivement donc je non je
je vais sortir des banalités par contre
ce que je peux dire mais sans aller trop
dans le détail c'est que je suis en
train de faire une investigation sur
général électrique Bfort en particulier
sur un point technique sur ce qu'on
appelle les prix de transfert
c'est-à-dire les profits qui partent du
site de Bfort en grande majorité vers la
Suisse et c'est ça qui m'a intéresse
parce que euh
ce qu'on sait en tout cas ce que
beaucoup savent que le site de général
électrique Bfort en fait il est
totalement compétitif et il fait de
l'argent euh mais que pour des raisons
voilà qui nous échappent euh et bien il
y a comment dire un
comment dire un déficit je dirais
artificiel qui crée et qui permet de
justifier un plan de licenciement plus
qu'important.
Voilà.
Alors, on on est-ce que est-ce que on
commence à parler de des montages
financiers maintenant de la crise
financière où on continue des petits
sujets légers ou
comme tu veux ? Moi, j'ai tout le temps.
On peut comme tu veux.
D'accord. Alors, on va parler de
l'enquête que tu es en train de faire en
ce moment et ensuite on parlera de de ta
perception du monde financier, de ta
perception de peut-être la crise qui
arrive. On va rentrer euh un petit peu
dans des questions où on va te demander
ton expertise.
On te laisse commencer par ce que tu
veux. Euh je euh moi je pensais par
exemple inaugurer le bal avec euh avec
la l'investigation que j'ai sortie pour
la web télé le le média donc sur les
épades le groupe d'épé les assurances
vie et aussi normalement il devait avoir
un troisème volet mais que je sortirai
plus tard sur les cliniques privées.
Quand tu sors un truc comme ça, est-ce
que c'est relu par un avocat ? Non, par
contre et là, je tiens à le remercier,
c'est euh bah déjà c'est relu par
plusieurs personnes de la rédaction en
long en travers. Et là, je je souhaite
vraiment remercier quelqu'un comme Théo
Caznav qui a donc qui est journaliste
euh au média qui a relu tous les
éléments. Il y avait un paquet de de de
comptes de de documents de contrats que
j'avais sorti sur cette investigation.
Et euh bon ça d c'était vraiment un
énorme boulot parce que moi je suis déjà
un moine bénédictin mais il a fallu
faire le même travail avec un deuxième
moine bénédictin. Et ensuite moi j'avais
rédigé donc l'article euh et lui il a il
a décidé à juste titre de parce que moi
je fais toujours je mets toujours un
petit côté personnel un peu comme dans
mon livre et cetera. Il a voulu plus
donner un côté journalistique à
l'article et je je suis absolument
d'accord avec ce qui ce qui a été fait.
Donc, on a sorti un long papier euh
peut-être un un peu trop long, un peu
technique, mais je pensais un très
important pour qu'on soit blindé au
maximum, donc de neuf pages sur euh sur
cette investigation euh donc sur les
épades privés, en particulier un groupe
de musvie euh sur les assurances vies et
euh voilà. Est-ce que est-ce que tu as
contacté ces organismes pour le
Oui. Donc j'ai contacté B j'ai contacté
tous les acteurs, j'ai contacté Demus,
j'ai contacté les actionnaires de
Domusvie, j'ai contacté les anciens
certains anciens actionnaires de
Domusie, j'ai contacté euh
des sources à l'intérieur de Domusui.
J'ai contacté la CPR qui est le alors ça
c'est sur le deuxième sujet. Donc en
restant que sur Domusi, qui est-ce
d'autre que j'ai contacté ? Euh je crois
que c'est tout. Et ensuite sur la
deuxième partie de l'investigation qui
sont les assurances VI, j'ai contacté
AXA Ardian qui est anciennement AXA
private equity. J'ai contacté euh
le régulateur financier concernant les
assurances VI qui s'appelle la CPR qui
dépend de la Banque de France.
Euh et une fois que j'ai fini
l'investigation, j'ai contacté trois
personnes. Mais une fois que c'était
bien terminé, he que c'était écrit, que
c'était vérifier tout ça, j'ai contacté
donc mes deux amis politiques, Fabien
Roussell, donc député PC, secrétaire
général du PCF et Hugo Bernal ici,
député FI. et j'ai contacté
une économiste qui est brillante qui
s'appelle Anne Lord deelat pour que j'ai
leur point de vue et voir ce qu'il avait
ce qu'on pouvait faire euh déjà en terme
politique avec les deux politiques et
aussi de de voir ce que experte comme
Anneordel pouvait ajouter en plus ou
même me dire valider ou non d'ailleurs
cette enquête.
Donc j'ai la chance, elle a elle a
vraiment passé donc l'économiste a
vraiment passé du temps ensuite à
regarder le dossier euh une fois que je
l'ai transmis. Donc ce dossier c'est
quoi ? C'est une affaire de gros sous ?
C'est une affaire qui est pas légale ?
C'est quoi ? C'est c'est simplement ton
biais idéologique qui te fait penser que
c'est pas légal ou que c'était c'est
allégal
alors
ou que c'est borderline mais légal ?
Alors déjà je veux dire un truc au
niveau idéologique. Je
fais l'avocé du diable. Oui, bien sûr.
Je me je pense que enfin, j'essaie de ne
jamais être aveuglé par l'idéologie.
Comment tu fais ?
Ben déjà, je considère que j'ai jamais
raison déjà pour commencer. Ensuite,
comme je te dis, même si ça paraît
simple, je fréquente des gens de tout
bord. Je suis pas là pour juger les les
les idéaux de chacun. Même
te la reprocher, je te coupe,
est-ce que on t'a reproché d'avoir un
spectre de de connaissance large ?
Euh, est-ce qu'on me l'a reproché ?
Euh pas pour le moment. Non non
euh
coup
non mais c'est pas grave, je t'en prie.
Euh donc oui sur les la question que tu
me posais sur Oui. sur les donc sur les
deux gros sujets en fait les trois
sujets mais les deux qui sont sortis
dans l'article. Un c'est un groupe d'PAD
privé. Il faut savoir qu'il y a trois
types d'PAD en France. Tuas les les
privés, les publics et les associatifs.
Donc les privés représentent 30 % du
marché. Et le groupe de Musvie, c'est le
troisème groupe des pates privés en
France derrière Corian et j'oublie le
deuxè
ça commence par un haut je crois enfin
bref.
Et ensuite tu as le ORPA et en ensuite
tu as Domusvie. En fait de Musvie moi je
me suis intéressé à Domusvie depuis des
années puisque euh quand j'ai
Est-ce que tu avais demandé de faire
remonter des choses ? Non, justement
c'est moi qui avais fermenté des
informations concernant euh un groupe
qui a été racheté par de musui qui
s'appelait Emerra. Euh et déjà à
l'époque, si tu veux, il y avait une
partie de l'actionnariat euh qui était
euh qui passait par la Suisse, ensuite
passait par Jersey si tu veux pour et
ensuite aller en France euh dans le
groupe Emér. Et moi, j'avais trouvé ça
curieux quand même en terme de voilà
qu'on fasse du business sur euh alors
là, c'était plus éthique et je dirais
fiscal, qu'on passe par les paradis
fiscaux pour remonter les profits du
business, enfin du business, tu vois ça
de de de c'est pas non plus une
industrie du service au aux anciens.
Donc j'avais j'avais déjà bon fait une
petite note là-dessus sur Emra. Emerra
ensuite a été racheté par Domusie. Je
peux je peux plus dire de de tête
l'année exacte. Enfin peu importe. Et
Domusvie si tu veux. Ce qui ce qui
m'intéresse. Il y a plein il y a plein
de choses dans Domusvie. Si on si tu
veux, on peut partir sur Domus déjà. Euh
Domus déjà tu
pas de diffamation.
Non pas de souci. Ah non non c'est
carré, c'est sourcé. Ça a été envoyé
d'ailleurs à ces gens-là. Donc euh
il y a pas de souci, ils m'ont juste dit
nos commentaires. No comment donc bah
oui no comment mais voilà euh en tout
cas pour la partie la partie anglaise
qui détient donc de musv est détenu à 55
%
à travers des des structures qui sont
dans les paradis fiscaux donc au
Luxembourg et à Jersety. Donc j'ai
remonté toutes les sociétés qui sont
dans l'article.
Ça c'est la première chose qu'on peut
dire. Donc tu as de l'action
actionnariat qui est offshore.
Euh il faut savoir ensuite que dans
l'actionnariat offshore euh il y a des
sociétés en bout chaîne rien qu'au
Luxembourg où tu n'as pas d'information
comptable. Ça c'est intéressant. Donc
opacité et ensuite les informations
comptables au niveau de Jerset et de qui
est l'actionnaire des sociétés
luxembourgeoises qui détiennent 55 % de
du groupe français. Tu n'as rien du
tout. Tu as zéro
genre société écran, c'est ça ?
Voilà. Alors, tu sais que c'est le
groupe ICG qui qui est un fond
d'investissement, mais tu ne sais pas
qui sont les personnes derrière parce
que en fait ces fonds là, comment dire ?
Ils mettent des personnes des personnes
qui sont riches ou bien des des des
voilà qui qui investissent dans des dans
des véhicules qui sont basés au
Luxembourg. Donc on ne sait pas qui sont
ces personnes.
Des véhicules financiers.
Oui, des véhicules financiers. Donc ça
c'est la première chose qu'on peut dire
sur cette partie de l'actionnariat.
Voilà. Légal ou c'est pas légal ? Ben
justement, on va le voir. Justement, on
va le voir. Et justement, on aussi
intérê jugé.
Non, non, on va le voir parce que ben je
vais t'en parler par la suite parce que
Mais tu n'es pas juge.
Ah non, je suis pas juge. Moi je ne juge
pas. Simplement, il y a des directives
européennes qui te disent que tel type
de de de montage et tel type de remontée
d'argent, c'est illégal ou tel type de
directive de l'OCDE, c'est illégal. Donc
moi, je suis certainement pas un juge.
Moi, je c'est uniquement fait encore des
faits.
Donc
donc il y a déjà pour résumer donc cette
remontée d'actionnariat
offshore et des profits qui remontent
offshore.
Maintenant, si on s'intéresse à une
autre partie de l'actionnariat, on va on
va s'intéresser après comment remonte
l'argent, mais à l'autre partie de
l'actionnariat en France, tu as donc Yve
Journel, monsieur Yve Journel qui est le
cfondateur de de Domusvie
qui possède en ce moment à travers son
véhicule d'investissement CIDVH 33 %
du reste du groupe de Musville.
Euh après, il y a encore plein d'autres
sociétés derrière. Il y a SRS, holding,
SRS sagesse.
Pour l'instant, il y a pas de souci.
Pour l'instant, tu as tu as tu as il y a
pas de problème. Je te décris juste le
la structure.
Et si DVH aussi, c'est intéressant de
noter que dedans euh 11 % de ICDVH est
détenu par un petit partenariat assez
sympathique, mais on y reviendra aussi
euh qui s'appelle FEF Capital. Donc
Franco Emirati Fund Capital qui est en
fait un partenariat entre à l'origine la
CDC donc la Caisse de dépôt et de
consignation
et le fond
et et pardon et le
j'ai un trou de mémoire et les et Abou
Dhabi et le voilà.
Ils ont le droit de faire des
partenariats ces gens-là.
Oui oui. Non, je je te décris juste la
structure le la chaîne de la chaîne
d'actionnariat. C'est exotique mais
c'est légal.
C'est exotique. Ouais, c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire. Donc 11 % de SIDVH
qui détient qui qui est détenu par
journal qui détient 33 % du groupe de
mususevie est basé en France.
Quand je me suis intéressé de savoir
comment le fond souverain
d'Abou Dhabi injecté du cash des Émirats
Arabes Unis, pardon, envoyé du du cash
dans ce dans cette société FEF Capitale,
j'ai pas eu de réponse de la part et
pourtant je les ai sollicité à
nombreuses reprises.
Il son pas obligé de te répondre
de BPI France qui est quand même financé
par Nossou.
Euh donc pas de réponse zéro parce qu'en
fait ils disent que c'est un partenariat
super sauf que c'est une SASU donc
c'est-à-dire une société unipersonnelle.
Donc pas de souci, ils peuvent très bien
euh apporter de la dette par exemple et
pas être actionnaire. D'accord, c'est
pas un problème. Mais déjà le montage
voilà pose des questions. C'est-à-dire
c'est un partenariat mais en fait c'est
une SASU. Bon ok
donc là c'est juste un petit peu pour
pour définir le périmètre.
Donc maintenant, parlons des remontées
de d'argent. Déjà, faut savoir, première
chose quand même peut-être, c'est que
cette les épades qui soient privés euh
public ou bien associatif, ils reçoivent
des dotations énormes de la part de
l'État. Donc
c'est quoi énorme ? C'est euh si tu
reprends ce qu'a dit Busin dernièrement
quand elle était encore aux affaires, je
crois que sur euh c'est plusieurs
milliards, c'est euh c'est ils sont
passés de financement de 5 à 10
milliards d'euros là dernièrement euh
ces deux dernières années. Si je crois
il y a une marge entre 5 et 10
milliards.
Alors euh je crois qu'ils vont
augmenter, excuse-moi, de 5 milliards à
10 milliards pour financer les ÉPAD.
Voilà, c'était son annonce. Faudra
vérifier avec la la
la communauté.
La communauté. Merci. Mais voilà, c'est
c'est l'annonce, je crois c'était 10
milliards. On va être bientôt à 10
milliards d'aide. Donc c'est la première
chose euh que également tu as les
départements qui aide qui financent les
ÉPAD. D'accord. Euh
et aussi dans le cadre de Musui, tu as
un financement qui est encore différent
des aides qui a le financement avec ce
que je te disais tout à l'heure de de
BPI France. Donc c'est de l'argent qui
vient en partie des Emmirats mais qui
vient aussi en partie de de l'argent des
des Français avec BPI France. Donc tu as
de l'argent qui qui vient de nos impôts,
qui vient de nous
et qui va remonter en partie donc dans
les paradis fiscaux. Donc ça pose une
question quand même. Après les galo,
tu sais que c'est c'est cet argent là
qui remonte.
Bah cette cette trésorerie là si tu
l'avais c'est c'est assz simple. Si tu
l'avais pas, tu es d'accord que tu ça
serait déduit de tes profits.
C'est aussi simple que ça. Donc c'est de
l'argent forcément.
OK, tu peux l'utiliser pour mais ce que
tu as en plus, tu le remontes dans les
paradis fiscaux.
C'est peut-être une stratégie
d'investissement futur.
Ouais, super. Ouais, bravo. Euh ensuite,
il faut savoir que la façon, là c'est la
partie un peu plus intéressante que la
façon dont remonte les profits le fond
d'investissement qui est basé au
Luxembourg à Jerset, il le fait de deux
façons. Il le fait à travers des un type
d'obligation convertible et un outil
hybride qu'on appelle CPEX.
Euh ça d'après quand on a discuté, on a
fait une visoconférence qui a été en
live sur le média une fois que j'ai
donner le dossier euh une fois
l'investigation faite à
la l'économiste Anne Lord de Lat, elle a
dit que selon elle, de ce qu'elle avait
vu, il y a des directives européennes
qui sont très claires, on a plus le
droit de faire ce genre de pirouette
voilà de de ramener du cash vers le
Luxembourg de cette façon-là. Donc
avant on avait le droit
avant oui parce que si tu veux le
Luxembourg ne joue pas le jeu. C'est ça
le truc. Donc c'est aussi simple que ça.
Il nous truande nous. Donc voilà.
Pourquoi tu dis qu'il nous truante ?
Bah c'est-à-dire ils font une loi qui
est différente de de ce que préconise
l'Europe. Donc
l'Irlande ils font pas pareil.
L'Irlande ils font pareil évidemment.
Les Pays-Bas font pareil. Malte fait
pareil.
En dehors.
En dehors. Oui. C'est c'est
Monaco.
Oui, pareil. C'est tout. Et
est-ce que la France fait la même chose
par rapport à d'autres pays ? Par
exemple, si les Émirats, si l'Arabie
Saoudite investit en France, est-ce que
la France est un paris fiscal pour
l'Arabie Saoudite ?
Un paradis fiscal, bah oui, évidemment,
elle va pas payer d'impôts ou très peu
d'impôts en remontant ses profits de la
France. Elle va passer par Luxembourg
avec des holdings, avec des poupées, des
structures de régime mère fille en
France. Elle va elle va quasiment pas
payer d'impôts. Évidemment, on est
enfin, on est même pas un paradis fiscal
pour l'Arabie Saoudite ou les Émirats
arabes unis. On est une une on est une
vache une vache à la quoi. Enfin,
tu dis ça ?
Bah si tu veux quand je vois euh
certains partenariat euh alors je pas
rentrer dans le détail parce que est-ce
que et l'argent qui remonte vers ces
pays-là ? Alors je sais alors je sais
bien que les gens à la tête de l'État
vont dire "Oui mais ils nous achètent de
l'armement." OK, super en contrepartie
mais il nous approvisionne en Mais non,
pour moi, on est extrêmement perdant ce
type de partenariat avec les avec ces
ces ces ces pays-là, on est perdant à
tous les niveaux si tu veux même pas
financièrement. C'est voilà,
on se coupe un bras,
on se Ouais. largement et on perd en
souveraineté, on coupe un bran, on n pas
besoin de leur sous, c'est n'importe
quoi.
Donc pour en revenir à la façon dont
l'argent remonte vers le Luxembourg,
donc déjà il y a ce type de de de dette
hybride. Donc voilà, ça rentrait dans
les détails. Donc ça c'est directive
européenne et aussi directive CDE qui
disent non, on on en veut plus, c'est
illégal et cetera.
Luxembourg qui ne joue pas le jeu. Euh
et ensuite, il y a un autre ce que je
marque aussi dans dans l'article, c'est
que il faut remonter des profits vers le
Luxembourg en se prêtant de l'argent le
groupe à à lui-même avec des taux
ahurissants. Tout le monde sait à
l'heure actuelle que les taux euh
d'emprunt sont au plus bas. Ils sont
proches de zéro, voire même négatif.
même on prête de l'argent, voilà pour on
donne de l'argent même. Euh sauf que là,
ils se prêtent à des taux qui sont et là
pas de diffamation. Je reprends
exactement leur document entre 9,2 % sur
9,20 % excuse-moi sur certains types de
dettes et 11 % sur certains types de
dettes. Ça c'est totalement anormal et
c'est aussi défini par des directives
européennes et de CDE, c'est illégal.
Donc ça c'est pas moi je juge pas, je
dis c'est il y a juste c'est écrit dans
dans la loi européenne et au niveau de
le CDE.
Euh ce que disait très bien alors sans
sans sans dévoyer ce que disait Anne
Lord de l'â lors de cette visoconférence
qui a été diffusé en live qui est sur
toujours sur Facebook et qui sera mis
sur YouTube prochainement, c'est que
d'un côté
on a l'Europe le CDE qui fait de plus en
plus un bon bout boulot pour essayer de
contrer toutes ces évasions fiscales et
et cetera, mais d'un autre côté on a des
acteurs en Europe qui ne jouent pas le
jeu et qui créent par exemple en 2016 au
Luxembourg ou dans ces années-là de des
types de véhicules spécialement qui euh
alors un véhicule c'est une boîte,
un véhicu c'est une boîte si tu veux,
c'est juste une société euh
luxembourgeoise par exemple euh
euh je mentionnais tout à l'heure au
début notre entretien de de société
luxembourgeoise en tout en hautre chaîne
dans lequel on avait absolument aucun
élément comptable et ça en fait le
Luxembourg a créé ce type de sociétélà
alors que c'est illégal au niveau
européen si tu veux euh juste ces
dernières années. Donc il joue pas le
jeu, il y a une ambivalence si tu veux.
Il il laisse créer toujours des petites
sociétés euh comme ça qui où il y a une
opacité absolue. Donc comme
comment tu peux tu peux affirmer qu'il
laisse peut-être que il
c'est eux qui créent ce type de de
société là au niveau législatif. Donc
ils savent très bien ce qu'ils font.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Question
d'internet. Comment comment il se
protège ? Comment il protège ? Alors,
c'est mal écrit les gars. Comment il se
protège pour éviter les diffamations ?
Alors, le meilleur moyen de se protéger
de la diffamation, c'est ça, c'est
simple, c'est l'effet, l'effet, l'effet,
toujours les faits et uniquement les
documents qui viennent de l'intérieur de
des sociétés que j'investigue.
Est-ce que tu as déjà subi des pressions
? Autre question d'internet ? Est-ce que
tu as subi des procédures billon ?
Non.
Est-ce qu'on a essayé de te faire fermer
ta bouche ?
Non. Non.
Des pression sur ta famille ?
Non.
un corbeau avec une petite lettre.
Non mais de toute façon ça marcherait
pas en fait. Si jamais il y avait un
truc comme ça, je pense ça
démultiplierait par 100 ma capacité de
d'embêtement. Donc c'est s'ils veulent
quand ils veulent. C'est voilà.
Donc voilà. Ouais. Euh
j'ai fait exprès de te déconcentrer.
Revenons au montage au véhicules.
Au véhicules. Donc concernant le
le véhicule, voilà. Donc il y a il y a
effectivement un cadre au niveau
européen pour lutter contre ce type de
contre l'évasion fiscale et ce type de
société. Mais d'un point de vue
législatif, le Luxembourg, les Pays-Bas,
l'Irlande, bah ils rusent un petit peu.
Ils essaient de voir ce qu'ils peuvent
faire et ils sortent assez souvent de ce
de enfin de temps à des structures qui
qui passent sous le radar si tu veux qui
permettent d'entrer dans l'opacité la
plus complète. Alors, je je vais faire
mon betta hein. Euh
pour bien comprendre ton énergie, ça
représente quel volume d'argent euh qui
est exfiltré de la France ? Alors
euh pour euh
si on parle de du groupe des pades là en
en alors le groupe des pades de
Museville euh en en moins de 2 ans, il a
fait partir vers le Luxembourg euh euh
105 millions d'euros de de remboursement
d'argent qui s'était apprêté, donc de
rembourse d'intérêt si tu veux. Donc
voilà, c'est ce que ça représente. C'est
pas rien euh sur une industrie.
Comment ça pèse Domus ?
Euh Domusvie, je je devrais te le dire,
euh il a été valorisé à la revente euh
en 2017 à 2,3 milliards d'euros. Autre
élément important si tu veux, donc là on
a parlé de des remontées de d'argent là
avec ces ces outils financiers qui sont
condamnés dans l'absolu par des
directives. Euh il faut ça,
on est sûr de ça ?
Ah oui oui, c'est sûr. Là-dessus, il y a
moi moi si tu veux, je cherche pas
embêter aussi ce que je tiens à dire. Je
cherche pas à embêter, ça m'amuse pas
d'embêter ces groupes si tu veux. J'ai
autre chose à faire.
Tu les embêtes ? Bah, tu sais, ils sont
vachement un cheval sur leur image de
marque. Ça les ennuie quand on sort des
on met la lumière sur eux, qu'on montre
la popote qu'ils font, ça les embête.
Moi, je cherche pas les embêter. Ça ça
me ça ça m'amuse pas spécialement. Je
suis pas un justicier. Euh je considère
juste que on a en droit de savoir ce qui
se passe. Euh voilà. Et j'ai absolument
rien contre eux. C'est juste je suis pas
d'accord mais j'ai pas de de sentiment
négatif à leur égard.
Non, en mathématique.
Non, pas spécialement. 105 millions
d'euros à 2,50 € le repas en ÉPADE, ça
fait combien de repas ? Bon, allez,
passons la moutade. Revenons à notre
véhicule financier. Est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres comme ça qui profitent euh
de mettre l'argent à gauche
de dans quel type d'industrie ? Dans
quel
Bah, d'autres groupes despad ou d'autres
groupes
Alors,
j'ai pas encore regardé. Alors, c'est
pour ça je vais pas pour le coup pas
faire de diffamation. Je n'en sais
absolument rien pour les deux premiers
groupes des pads français. Je sais que
je suis intéressé pour regarder ce qui
se passe. Donc je regarderai le moment
venu. Euh après, pour revenir euh pour
le
euh sur aussi euh comment dire, il faut
savoir que en en 2017 euh concernant
Domusville, tu as cet actionnaire ICG
donc qui est basé au au Luxembourg à
Jersy qui a racheté départ un autre fond
d'investissement qui s'appelle PAI.
Euh et il faut savoir que euh
comment Yve Journel à l'époque ne
possédait pas 33 % du groupe, il en
possédait moins et que euh donc c'est de
l'argent euh publque en partie avec BPI
France puisque c'est BPI France qui l'a
aidé à racheter des actions de son
groupe à un fond d'investissement. Donc
là aussi ça pose d'autres questions pour
moi. Alors déjà éthique, comment ça se
fait si tu veux qu'on aide des
oligarques français à se racheter euh de
à des actions de leur propre groupe euh
qui et et cet argent ils vont le donner
à des fonds d'investissement qui sont
basés offshore si tu veux tout ça c'est
quand même super trouble quoi. Je veux
dire ça pose des questions.
Euh donc c'est déjà ce qu'on peut dire
sur les remontées d'argent sur
l'actionnariat. Après, il y a d'autres
choses aussi que je surveille et là
c'est pareil sans vouloir faire de
diffamation, mais juste par expérience
de Musu, il a son actionnariat au
Luxembourg à Jersy. Moi dans mon
expérience quand je travaillais dans la
finance et je le vois aussi encore avec
tout ce que j'investigue, les fonds
d'investissement, pourquoi aussi ils
aiment bien se vendre entre eux les
investissements ? Parce que par exemple,
tu as tu as un groupe qui fait des
valises, on va dire, sans donner le nom.
Euh, il est basé, on va dire, à Jersy et
puis tu as un autre gros fond
d'investissement anglo-saxon qui
l'entreprise, on va dire, elle est en
France et tuas un autre gros fond
d'investissement
américain qui ils vont faire, si tu veux
la plusvalue, ils vont se racheter l'un
va racheter à l'autre le comment dire le
ils vont faire la transaction de rachat
au niveau offshore et pas au niveau
français. Et donc le fisque ne va pas
être au courant parce qu'il y avoir très
peu d'informations qui vont filtrer,
elles seront pas suffisantes. Le fisque
ne veut pas être au courant de du
montant de la transaction. Donc c'est
aussi encore un autre exemple parmi tant
d'autres de pourquoi
on appelle les dark pool.
Les dark pool ça me dit rien. En terme
de de de label. Non, ça me dit rien.
Mais voilà, c'est alors peut-être que je
devrais le savoir mais désolé. Euh mais
donc et bon, j'en ai j'en ai parlé avec
euh quelqu'un du syndicat de de
Bery, le syndicat majoritaire de Bercy
qui est solidarité euh finances
publiques. Ils m'ont dit euh pas de
souci, on on suit ça. Il y a une cellule
qui suit ce genre de truc. Bon, même si
je sais qu'ils ont très peu de moyens.
Donc voilà, je
Donc là, je j'en profite pour poser une
question internet. Question en rapport
avec l'actualité. Est-ce que Bercy
tolère ou est-ce que Bercy ne voit pas ?
C'est ben c'est pareil, les choses sont
jamais monolithiques. Euh là je j'en
profite pour euh tu par la question
parle de Bery. Euh
j'ai invité dernièrement à l'école de
guerre économique. Tu as invité il y a
pas longtemps son directeur Christian
Arbuot qui est un ami. Euh j'ai invité à
l'école de guerre économique avec deux
amis euh que je salue
euh euh
donc la secr la pardon la porte-parole
de la porte-parole de du du syndicat
majoritaire de Bercy pour qu'elle nous
explique ce qui se passait à Berta
une cinquantaine à l'école de guerre
économique. D'ailleurs, il y a un
enregistrement qu'a fait Adrien Ramati
George qui est une des deux personnes
avec Alban Géolet qui ont fait le
l'enregistrement et qui ont reçu donc la
porte-parole. On avait tous envie de
pleurer à la fin si tu veux. On a un
gouvernement qui est en train de nous
casser
qui est en train de nous casser un un
comment dire le la DG FIP donc la
direction enfin Ber quoi si tu veux.
Enfin bon DG fib c'est pas que Bercy
c'est DG FIFIP Douan et INC mais on a on
a un gouvernement qui est en train de de
nous casser de plus que malmener le
la la DG fib. Bon après on peut rentrer
dans le détail parler de la loi et
cetera.
Euh moi, tu vois la lo syndical. Le
syndicat, pourquoi vous pleuriez ?
Bah parce que on voit que toute cette
culture qui est forte en France de
connaissance du terrain est en train
d'être détruite euh grâce à au suur
Macron. Et je veux dire, on sait
malheureusement que comment dire la DG
FIP n'a pas une extrême bonne, tu vois,
c'est pas très sexy dans l'absolu dans
dans l'esprit des gens quoi. Si tu veux,
le les impôts c'est pas les les voilà,
c'est pas le grand amour en règle
générale. Euh mais on en a besoin, c'est
nécessaire. Et euh et là c'est clair que
le le les fonctionnaires de de cette
administration sont très mal menés. Pour
te donner une idée, ils étaient 130000
il y a quelques années, ils sont passés
à 100000. Dans 3 ans, 40 % partent à la
retraite. Il y en a pas beaucoup qui
vont te remplacer et la majorité des
gens qui rentrent sont des des
contractuels. Et ça c'est rien, c'est
qu'un exemple parmi euh Moi, je te je
t'invite si je peux me
Je peux t'objecter. Ils sont payés une
fortune. Non non, les gens qui sont à la
tête. Oui, mais pas les pas les pas les
gens qui pas les les petits
fonctionnaires catégorie CBA. Non non
non. Après, si tu as des des gens à
Bersi qui sont à 200000 balles, ça je
sais qu'il y a des choses qui sont
sorties à juste titre, c'est
inacceptable. Euh qui d'ailleurs font
après les les va et viens qu'on connaît
avec les les qui bossent dans les fonds
d'investissement et cetera. Euh mais
non, il y a il y a une nécessité pour un
état construit et une souveraineté de de
d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas un
hasard. Notre souveraineté est détruite
vole en éclat un peu plus chaque jour et
en même temps tu as tu as tu as cette
administration qui elle qui qui vole en
éclat également.
Alors, si on donne sans rentrer 30 dans
le détail, moi je je t'invite à enfin je
te je t'invite je te suggère d'inviter
par exemple
une personne du de ce syndicat par
exemple Vincent Dreuset ou Anne Guillaot
euh Anne Guuyot et pour qu'il puisse
t'expliquer en détail ce qui se passe
parce que
les gens non
on sait ce qui se passe.
OK. Bon ouais, c'est voilà, je m'en
doutais mais bon par exemple aussi avec
la loi si tu veux, ce qui est horrible
que euh une partie énorme du travail des
impôts va être externalisée vers les
commissaires au compte et les DAF, donc
les directeurs
financiers euh et qui vont si tu veux,
on va vers une société, même pas
l'angloaxone, je veux dire, c'est en
fait le commissaire au compte qui va
valider valider les impôts et qui va
dire pas de souci, le montage offshore
nickel. il est très bien et vous avez
pas le droit de vous salarié ou syndicat
de de dire que c'est pas bien. Vous
pouvez même pas l'attaquer.
Donc en fait il va falloir comme on dit
le le diable est dans les détails. Il
faut vraiment regarder dans le détail de
cette loi soc qu'il y a derrière. Et
franchement c'est pas que ça fait peur,
c'est c'est une attaque grave de notre
souveraineté.
Voilà,
on reviendra sur la souveraineté dans
dans 5 minutes. Juste une question. Donc
le fait de entre guillemets
euh de faire de l'optimisation fiscale
parce que pour l'instant on peut dire
que de l'optimisation fiscale, toi tu
penses que c'est toi tu penses que c'est
c'est pas légal. Ah non, j'ai j'ai je te
cite juste des directives européennes.
Je je moi je suis pas le juge.
Donc question, j'ai entendu dire que il
y avait des participations des salariés
en fait qui partaient de l'autre côté et
donc il y a les participations de
salariés qui sontah
concernant domvie si tu veux aussi ce
qui est un peu terrible en plus de
l'argent qui touche au niveau étatique
au en plus des remonter vers les paradis
fiscaux. Il y a un autre point qui est
qui est inacceptable à mon sens, c'est
qu'une partie très importante des
salariés de musie, il y en a quand même
15400 si je dis pas de bêtises, euh ou
14500 enfin euh qui ne touchent pas leur
participation. Alors c'est quoi la
participation ? C'est ça a été inventé
par de Gaulle, c'est
une prime sur
qui qui est payé grâce au profits qui
sont faits de de l'entreprise, si tu
veux, issu des profits de l'entreprise.
Or, je me suis rendu compte et là, j'ai
les documents et les informations que en
fait pour échapper à ce genre de
paiement en grande majorité euh à la
majorité de ses une grande partie de ses
salariés, de musv fait croire que il est
pas un groupe dans l'absolu et qu'il a
pas d'unité économique et sociale.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, je sais pas, je
sais plus combien exactement de dépat
d'établissement, mais ils disent que
chaque établissement indépendant l'un de
l'autre et que donc ce qui fait que tu
as plein d'établissements qui ont moins
de 50 salariés,
tu vois, ils sont ils sont malins.
C'est façon Microsoft ça, non ?
Ouais. Ouis. Voilà. Exactement. Donc il
faudrait dans l'idéal que pour il
faudrait qu'il y a un juge qui qualifie
l'unité économique et sociale mais ça
veut dire voilà partir dans des actions
juridiques avec les syndicat tout ça
sachant que c'est très compliqué mais
c'est pour te montrer l'argusie qui
j'utilise. Donc sachant qu'en plus avec
le Covid ce qui est on sait que ces
gens-là sont en première ligne que c'est
eux qui font tourner le pays. Ben en
plus bah leur participation elle part
dans les paradis fiscaux. Donc comment
moi quand je vois ça pour l'instant il y
a pas encore la crise financière. Elle
va arriver, elle va être violente, la
plus violente qu'on est connu. Tout le
monde s'accorde à dire ça.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi
elle va être violente ? Pourquoi
pourquoi elle va être violente ? Parce
qu'il y a jamais autant de cash et
autant de dans dans le système que
maintenant et parce que il y a jamais eu
autant de richesse que maintenant. Donc
si tout d'un coup tu habitué, même la
toute petite couche moyenne française
habitué à un certain standing, le jour
où ça se casse la gueule, je suis pas
certain que tout le monde soit d'accord.
Il y en a qui qui accepteront, qui
feront leur jardin, qui seront dans de
l'entraide, qui sont dans des
colocations, mais je pense qu'il y a
plein de gens jeunes ou ou
anciens qui diront "Non, c'est j'ai
toujours cru en ce système. C'est hors
de question que ce système s'effond."
Donc, il y aura forcément une sorte de
violence qui qui se dégagera de de cette
de cette crise financière.
Enfin, c'est mon avis. Après euh
continue sur la crise que tu anticipes.
Oui, enfin que j'anticipe que tout le
monde anticipe. Euh Ah oui, je peux te
donner une anecdote ? En fait, il y a
j'ai une il y a un en fait c'est un
nouveau contact, un ami aussi que j'ai
eu en grâce en en en en allant faire une
conférence à l'école de guerre
économique. Et en fait, c'est grâce à
toi parce que tu à la fin du de la
première première interview que que tu
as que j'ai fait ici, tu avais parlé de
l'école de guerre économique. Ensuite,
ils m'ont contacté et euh et il y a un
une personne que j'ai rencontré là-bas
qui est je pas citer son nom, qui est
vraiment super, un super ami euh qui est
vraiment très très haut placé dans la
finance française depuis très longtemps
et qui j'ai eu assez longuement à un
moment donné au téléphone pendant le
pendant le confinement et qui m'a dit
"Écoute, c'est horrible ce qui se passe
ce qui se passe avec le Covid, avec ce
que le le le
manque d'organisation, pardon, de de
l'État Mais ce qui me fait encore plus
peur, c'est la crise financière qui va
venir et il y aura beaucoup plus de
morts et ça va être terrible. C'est
pour cet automne, c'est ça ? Ah non mais
ça je peux pas te prédire mais ça peut
être dans 12 mois 18 mois c'est mais
mais on la viv on la vivra de notre
vivant si ça voilà c'est c'est sûr et
dans euh puis quand on entend d'autres
personnes comme Jean Kovici euh qui est
un un habitué ici qui dit que le pic du
pétrole c'est à peu près peut-être dans
10 ans que il y a d'autres sources qui
disent entre 5 et 10 ans. Tu vois bien
que tous les
Pourquoi cette corrélation ? Parce que
si on se tape une crise financière, le
pétrole on s'en fout, il va être
Oui, bien sûr aussi, mais l'économie est
basée euh
consommation énergétique.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc si tu veux, si
tout ça ça arrive un peu en même temps,
bon le le le crash va être d'autant plus
important et violent. Euh moi ce qui me
enfin ce qui me fait peur entre
guillemets, c'est pas tant le fait que
les gens perdent de l'argent parce qu'on
en perdra de l'argent. C'est c'est
irrémédiable. Ça sera irrédiable.
Perdra de l'argent ou perdra du pouvoir
d'achat.
On perdra du de l'argent et du pouvoir
d'achat les deux. Ce qui peut-être de
façon irrémédiable en plus. Euh ce qui
ce qui ça c'est pas un problème dans
l'absolu parce que en fait ça nous
obligera à être plus intelligent, à être
plus créatif et à vivre dans l'entraide
euh peut-être à travailler moins, à plus
faire son jardin et tout ça et à moins
avoir des idées de carrière ou de ça.
Par contre, le problème qui risque
d'arriver, c'est euh
pour tous ceux et celles qui ont cru
dans ce système pendant toutes ces
années là, la la désillusion va être
énorme. Et pour moi la c'est cette
désillusion qui peut se transformer en
violence qui est potentiellement
dangereuse. Quand on voit déjà comment
l'État enfin les personnes à la tête de
l'État plus exactement
ont géré de mains de maître la la le
Covid, on peut déjà imaginer aussi la
main de maître, la façon dont ils vont
gérer le la la crise financière qui va
arriver.
C'est-à-dire
voilà, là on a eu un crash test, ça
s'est pas bien passé. Donc le prochain
crash test, je pense que ça ça se
passera pas très bien non plus. Le crash
test en question, c'était l'épidémie.
C'est ça.
Ouais, l'épidémie c'est un crash test
quelque part. C'est c'est presque enfin
c'est c'est pas c'est une image mais
c'est comme si la nature nous nous
envoyait un un petit crash test en
disant "Regardez là, je vous envoie un
petit truc."
Est-ce que tu as peur Est-ce que tu as
peur que pour le le deuxième crash
testit par exemple des montages
financiers qui soient passés genre sous
l'effet de la crise ?
Oui, bien sûr. Ça c'est le risque. C'est
le risque. Et c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait la deuxième partie
de mon investigation.
euh qui est sur les assurances vies.
Donc les assurances vies en chiffre,
c'est 1800 milliards d'euros. Donc c'est
le plus gros placement français pour
pour vous rendre compte, c'est le budget
de l'État 2019, c'est 7 sep 7 fois moins
quand même. Donc voilà, en terme de en
fait, c'est notre pactol en France,
c'est le fond souverain qu'on a qu'on a
pas, c'est en fait c'est enfin qu'on a,
on l'a avec le les assurances. Donc cet
énorme pactol, moi ce que je sais depuis
des années parce que les assurances vi
ça m'intéresse, c'est là où il y a plus
d'argent. Mon livre c'est là où l'argent
ça à faire toi tu t'intéresses aux
assurants de vie
le truc vraiment ce que tu dis c'est ce
que tu dis dans ta soirée Tinder
ah oui tu tu vois j'ai pas de soirée
Tinder. Tu imagines un petit peu comment
mon ami en a marre de tu vois les
soirées avec Maxime, c'est on parle
assurance vie, placement offshore et
crise financière. Donc je te dis pas
l'ampers. Donc
revenons aux assurances vies.
Aux assurances vies. Les assurances vies
en fait il y a une partie très
importante. Quel que soit le groupe là
j'ai pris l'exemple d'AXA en particulier
mais aussi les autres les compétiteurs
qui envoient l'insu des souscripteurs
des assurances vi cet argent dans les
paradis fiscaux. Alors, c'est pareil. Tu
vas me dire "Ouais, quel est le problème
?" Euh, bon euh planification fiscale,
optimisation et ou ça ? Oui, pourquoi
pas ? Déjà, ça pose quand même une
question. Est-ce que les gens sont
courants qu'on envoie l'argent vers Jers
de leurs économies ? Déjà quand même.
Première question. Deuxième question
quand même qui est beaucoup plus
intéressante, c'est que et on en revient
donc à ces véhicules d'investissement
OPAC, c'est quand tu passes de l'argent,
quand AXA euh
donne enfin transverse une partie de
l'assurance vie de ces souscripteurs
vers une société qui veut la gérer pour
elle, qui est ardient, qui est
anciennement Axapravity et qui monte un
fond. Je donne un exemple précis dans
l'article justement, j'aurais pu donner
une centaine puisque c'est le cas de
centaines de fonds en France. à Jerset
déjà dès jersy tu ne sais pas déjà qui
est dans le fond déjà pour commencer
parce que ça sera pas que l'argent de
l'assurance vie ça sera plein d'autres
personnes.
première chose et deuxième chose, tu ne
sais pas dans quel investissement et ça
c'est grave va l'argent et et en fait tu
n'as aucun document comptable de dans
les dans l'article que j'ai fait, tu
n'as aucun document comptable qui prouve
euh dans quoi l'argent de l'assurance
vie dans cet exemple précis.
Et ça c'est je te dis j'ai des centaines
de j'ai des centaines d'exemples comme
ça pas que pour que ça pour pour plein
d'autres. Donc c'est un deuxième
problème extrêmement important. Où va
cet argent et pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
cette opacité qu'organisé ? Moi quand je
prends l'exemple de cette société basée
à Jersey qui s'appelle ASF7, je sais que
il va ensuite dans le fond souverain
Mubadala. On revient encore vers les
bon, j'ai fait un peu exprès. On revient
vers Abu Dhabi. Voilà. Donc il faut
savoir que Mubadala donc l'argent de
l'assurance vie française passe dans la
société jersienne. ASF7 va ensuite dans
Mubadala le fond souverain. Fond
souverain la même entité qui nous achète
de l'armement. La même entité qui a
investi dans l'armement russe Russian
Hélicopts.
La même société qui a placé euh
[Musique]
15 milliards. Alors j'ai peut-être un
doute là. Donc je je vais dire au moins
10 milliards. On va rester à 10
milliards parce que j'ai un doute.
Excuse a passé 10 milliards dans le plus
gros fond d'investissement des nouvelles
tech au fond qui s'est cassé la gueule
dernièrement qui s'appelle Softbank
Vision Fund qui a perdu qui a perdu 16
milliards là pour le coup en quelques
mois qu' obligé de vendre ses actions
qu'elle a dans Alibaba pour se refaire.
Et euh voilà. Donc moi je tout
simplement j'ai demandé à Axa
donc là je te je te je c'est juste un
exemple de trans demandé
accer
s'il pouvait me dire donc j'aurais donné
tout toute un email j'ai envoyé un email
très très précis de de tout le transfert
d'argent des montants, des
investissements et cetera, un truc comme
ça. Bah tu vois pour pas être attaqué en
diffamation quoi. Je veux dire moi je
cherche pas les embêter.
Il m'
Je vois bien le directeur financier
d'Axa en train de s'arracher les
cheveux, perdre ses sourcils et là ils
ont été j'ai une dame en premier assez
haut placée qui m'a dit je suis pas la
bonne personne, je vous
je vous guide vers telle personne qui
était voilà je me rappelle plus son nom
mais dans dans l'argonigramme qui est
très très haut. Il m'a dit "Vous sortez
l'article quand ? C'est quand la
deadline ?" Je lui dis "Tel jour, il m'a
dit "OK, je reviens vers vous." Il est
jamais revenu vers moi. Première chose,
un truc comme ça, normalement tu
reviens. Qui t'a ni en bloc ou qui t'a
dire voilà première chose. Ensuite, je
suis allé vers Ardian. Ardient donc en
AXA Prvity qui gère une partie de de
l'argent d'Axa. Et Ardian m'a fait deux
réponses que je trouve ubuesque à dormir
debout.
Quand je leur ai demandé de façon très
spécifique où partait l'argent et
pourquoi on avait pas d'éléments
comptables et d'éléments de sur les
investissements faits de cette société
jersienne, ils m'ont ils m'ont rien dit
dans le premier email, ils m'ont juste
dit "Ne vous inquiétez pas parce que
j'avais parlé de Mubadala et tout ça et
de l'armement, il a dit ils ont dit on
ninvestit pas dans de l'armement et ça
et d'ailleurs on n'est pas au courant de
ce genre de de c'est là où voilà je veux
dire il devrait être au courant si MAD
investi dans l'armement ou pas." Enfin
bon, bref,
ça regarde pas.
Bah je sais pas, il place de l'argent de
façon importante, hein, que ce font
c'est
enfin c'est énorme quoi. Je veux dire
quand tu places de l'argent, tu ess un
petit peu c'est la moindre des choses en
tu fais de l'intelligence économique, tu
vois où tu tu réfléchis, où tu places
ton argent quand même. Les risques, tu
mesures les risques. Alors, j'en viens à
cette question. Est-ce que tu penses que
les assurances vies françaises sont en
danger en cas de crise financière ?
Parce que
Oui, absolument, absolument. Euh elles
sont en parce que déjà il y a cette en
enlevant l'aspect euh partir dans les
paradis fiscaux. Là on en parle même
pas, c'est pas grave, on s'en moque en
en grand prince aujourd'hui. Voilà,
Grand Prince, voilà, je vous le donne le
truc. Euh non, si on regarde uniquement
sur l'opacité, là il y a de quoi pour le
coup, j'ai plus de cheveux mais vraiment
de s'arracher les cheveux et c'est euh
je veux pas créer un un assurance vie
bankrun là, mais franchement je voilà,
je moi j'aurais ce genre d'argent, je
chercherai plutôt à leur tirer à l'heure
actuelle. Alors
moi je vais me faire l'avoquer du
diable. Oui.
Et je vais te dire, les assurances vies
en général sont basées sur des
obligations d'état.
Pas toutes. Pas toutes. Non. Non. Une
partie, oui, mais une autre partie très
importante dans des investissements des
sociétés privées.
Voilà. Tu veux que je t'en dise plus ?
Ouais, bah bien sûr. Crois que tu es
venu ici pour pousser un cadit, mec.
Euh
donc oui, voilà. En fait, moi le risque
c'est que enfin moi j'en suis quasi sûr
si tu veux quand la crise financière va
arriver, il y a toutes ces sociétés dans
lesquelles on a investi l'argent qui
sont dans des paradis fiscaux, dans des
investissements
qui soient légaux ou pas, ou bidon ou
pas, ou toxique ou pas, ça va se casser
la gueule et il y aura plein de
montagement frauduleux. On pourra jamais
mettre la main dessus. Ça ça n'engage
que toi. Ça
ça n'engage que moi. Et je parle pas
d'accès je dis en règle générale dans le
monde des assurances vi et des banques.
Et euh le le jour où ça se cassera la
gueule la la
comment dire la crise aura bonu parce
qu'on dira bah c'est la crise, c'est pas
de notre faute. Tu vois bien ? Et c'est
ça aussi le il faut voir que le les
paradis fiscaux ça sert aussi à ça, pas
uniquement d'évasion fiscale, ça sert
aussi à anonymiser les transactions
parce que là en l'espèce, on sait pas où
l'argent part pour une partie de
l'argent des des fonds. Et c'est aussi
ça euh déresponsabilise les gens qui
font les montages. Tu es bien d'accord ?
Parce que là, on sait pas, on pourra pas
venir leur faire des procès, les mettre
en prison puisqu'on sait pas où va
l'argent.
Et ensuite moi quand j'ai j'ai été un
peu horrifié des réponses et non
réponses de Axardian contacté donc le
régulateur financier la CPR
Allô la police
allô la police qui m'ont fait un email
franchement les gars enfin un truc
générique voilà j'ai dit non c'est pas
la question que je vous pose les
questions que je vous pose sont des
questions techniques que j'ai envoyé
accès à Ardient pouvez-vous me répondre
sur et pas de réponse à à à cet email
de réponse. C'est peut-être arrivé dans
la boîte de spam.
Non non non non non, j'avais déjà une
réponse de pas de souci. Non non, pas de
réponse parce que pas de réponse quoi.
Alors aussi je le sais parce que on a
fait cette visionférence une fois qu'on
a euh sorti l'investigation écrite et
une petite vidéo qui a été faite. Donc
j'ai fait une visoconférence avec comme
je te disais les deux députés et
l'économiste Anlor de Lat.
Euh il faut savoir aussi si on veut être
gentil avec eux qu'ils ont très peu de
moyens et que dans l'absolu
pas forcément ou pas vraiment ou c'est
dans leur prérogative forcément de
regarder où va l'argent. Enfin, ils
peuvent voir mais bon en fait tant que
tu as pas un juge, tant que tu as pas un
scandale, un X voilà, tant que le
business tourne,
tout roule quoi.
Donc dans le cas dans le cas où ils
peuvent pas payer les assurances vies ou
si les gens sortent des des produits de
d'assurance vie, qu'est-ce qui se passe
si on peut pas rembourser ? Bah rien, on
pourra pas rembourser, c'est tout.
On est on l'a dans l'os.
Ben oui, on dira que c'est la crise et
que c'est pas de chance, c'est tout.
C'est quoi tes préconisations ? Euh
alors des choses très simples vraiment
truc comme bon sens paysan vraiment dans
les petites j'ai donné une conférence
gratuite à doué juste avant le une des
dernières que j'ai donné à doué juste
avant le le confinement
et j'ai parlé justement des assurances
vi à un moment donné et aussi et
j'aurais dit
parce qu'il y a pas mal de quelques
personnes qui avaient des assuran
j'aurais dit écoutez si vous avez des
enfants ou des proches qui ont besoin de
financer je sais pas moi un appartement
une maison, une maison à la campagne, un
terrain à la campagne pour mettre un
verger ou j'en sais rien. Au lieu que ça
soit la banque qui prête, bah sortez
votre argent de l'assurance vie.
Prêtez-leur de l'argent, quitte à le
sécuriser auprès d'un notaire en le
faisant euh comment dire notariser pour
que pour que le le terrain soit soit
sécurisé au voilà.
Donation du vivant, c'est ça ?
Bah forcément, non, même pas une
donation, que ça soit même un prêt si tu
veux et que les les et que ça leur fasse
un revenu plus tard si tu veux. euh
cherche le le terme technique.
Bref, c'estàdire que le le le
nantissement, excuse-moi, le
nantissement, c'estàdire que le terrain
par exemple où la maison est nantie sur
voilà.
Euh donc jeurais dit voilà, c'est-à-dire
que vous sécurisez vous déjà vous aidez
mais tu as pas le droit de donner des
conseils financiers.
Non, c'est pas des conseils, c'est
voilà, ils me disent "Qu'est-ce que vous
ferez à notre place ?" Moi je donne pas
de conseils financiers, c'est je suis
pas pas
Donc c'est ce que je ferais. un truc
tout simple, c'estàdire j'aiderai mes
proches euh
tout simplement et si vraiment je suis
vieux et que je souhaite avoir quandême
un petit peu un petit matelas, ben je me
ferai rembourser à taux zéro le le
l'argent que j'ai prêté à mes enfants ou
neveux, niè ou frère, sœur et cetera ou
oncle et tante, peu importe. Donc
quelque chose de très basique si tu
veux, tu vois. Euh mais puis je pense
qu'il va falloir aussi qu'on accepte que
l'argent va être perdu quoi qu'on fasse
aussi. C'est enfin
perdu dans dans quel sens il euh
bah perdu comme un dans un trou noir
quoi. C'est-à-dire que une fois que par
exemple tu as comme tout le monde le
sait c'est la dette qui crée l'argent en
fait. Euh une fois que tu as la dette
qui se casse la gueule ben tout va ça va
partir dans une sorte de vortex quoi.
Enfin j'image le truc mais on peut pas
dire mais disons voilà c'est
Est-ce que tu as cherché à contacter le
ministère de la défense ?
Non mais tu rigoles avec le profil que
j'ai.
Pourquoi je rigole ? Ben
c'est c'est eux qui t'ont décrété person
grat ?
Non non, c'est pas eu ça en a un autre.
Euh je je sais qu'il y a une autre
personne dont je je dirai le nom euh qui
a essayé de me mettre en relation avec
des personnes dernièrement euh du
ministère de la défense.
Euh il m'a dit "Ouais, normalement untel
euh bon voilà va t'appeler." Non il a
pas appelé. Donc je pense que pour
l'instant ils sont encore un peu
échaudés. Voilà peut-être d'ailleurs à
Vitternam pas grave hein. Moi je veux
dire je développe mes réseaux au niveau
local avec mes amis il y a pas de souci.
à ton avis, ils sont au courant qu'ils
vont être obligés de gérer la merde ou
pas ?
Alors ça c'est le gros
pour les podcasts qui ne les podcasteurs
qui ne te voient pas, tu as fait quoi
avec ta bouche là ? J'ai fait un espèce
de
de proute avec ma bouche. Euh écoute,
c'est après c'est comme je dis, c'est
jamais monolitique. Tu as toujours des
gens qui font du bon boulot, qui sont
super, y compris même des énarques, des
polytechniciens et tout ça, c'est pas le
problème. Euh mais euh mais c'est plutôt
mal parti. Oui, effectivement, je pense
pas qu'il y a de plan B pour le moment
euh
qu'il soit là pour protéger euh le
peuple. Ça va être là des bacles
ça. Je peux je peux pas dire en fait j'y
réfléchis pas. Moi je je suis dans mes
investigations, je suis dans mes réseaux
d'amitié. Dit que tu discutais avec ta
femme de crise financière.
Oui. Non, quand je dis crise financière,
excuse de Oui. Disons sur les Oui.
assurance vie tout ça. Oui, je mais ça
je développe pas, j'imagine pas ce qui
se qui peut qui pourrait se passer. Je
pense que d'ailleurs la seule façon que
je pourrais imaginer, ça serait d'écrire
vraiment un roman, tu vois, où tu peux
avoir toute la liberté, où tu es pas
obligé de de penser en terme de de
finances et d'économie où tu peux tout
te permettre. Et ça, je peut-être
quelque chose que j'écrirai en janvier.
J'ai peut-être envie de le faire, mais
euh mais j'ai pas envie de dire de toute
fois de faire un rapport en disant tel
risque, tel risque et tel risque. Enfin,
je pourrais le faire mais pour le
moment, je préfère sortir des
investigations
euh qui touchent directement à mon à mon
sens les citoyens, même si il y en a qui
marchent bien, d'autres qui sont moins
relayés. Euh voilà. Mais euh
est-ce que tu es proche du moins à ta
femme à force de parler crise financière
de de ce que tu penses vicié ou ce que
tu as ou tes enquêtes où tu as imaginé
que c'était vicié ou que ça l'it ?
Est-ce que est-ce que tes proches ils te
regardent pas de travers en disant "Tu
nous stresses, tu es un corbeau".
Des choses comme ça. Alors avant
peut-être avant qu' qu'il n'apprenne que
tu étais une source
euh maintenant ça donne quoi ? Alors
maintenant, bah si des fois juste mon
ami me dit "Bon, tu vas peut-être
arrêter d'en parler un peu là." Voilà,
c'est tout ce que je fais tout de suite.
J'arrête tout de suite. Mais avec les
amis, non, justement, c'est plutôt eux
qui sont demandeurs
maintenant.
Maintenant, vraiment. Ouais, vraiment
énormément demandeurs.
Si tu me permets d'être vulgaire
parce qu'il se chient dessus.
Non, oui, enfin pour beaucoup bah c'est
normal, il y en a qui sont qu' charge de
famille. Moi j'ai pas charge de famille.
Il y en a qui ont de l'argent de côté.
Tout enfin moi ça me je je juge pas. Je
comprends, je comprends largement. Euh
et on essaie de aussi le but c'est aussi
d'essayer de trouver des solutions à
notre petit niveau. Donc et on voit que
ce qui marche le mieux, c'est l'entraide
et et c'est pas de faire des grosses
économies et c'est pas de de de viser
des grosses carrières et de continuer
dans c'est de mettre un pas de côté en
fait.
Donc voilà. Donc j'en profite. En fait,
j'en ai pas parlé mais dans dans je te
parle du réseau d' enfin de réseau,
c'est c'est des amis vraiment de de tout
bord et tout horizon. Euh là euh
je te parlais par exemple de gilet
jaune. Là je de je pense par exemple à à
Besançon à à Frédéric Guillaume qui est
un de mes amis qui qui a qui qui a subi
des harcèlements euh judiciaires euh qui
euh qui a été euh qui a eu deux procès
en cours. Euh donc moi, j'ai été aux
deux procès. En cours, on en parle pas.
Ah ok. Ok d'accord. Et voilà. OK
d'accord. Bah il y en a un deuxième,
excuse-moi. Il a étaé relaxé maison
l'autre OK, on en parle pas. Et en tout
cas voilà, je suis je suis à ses côtés.
Dès que je peux faire une tribune, j'en
ai fait une, une une euh comment dire
comment quand tu signes là une pétition,
on a eu 3000 personnes qui ont signé la
pétition pour aller en sa faveur. Voilà,
dès que je peux, je suis à ses côtés.
Donc au niveau local, que ça soit avec
des des amis syndicalistes, avec des
amis gilets jaunes, avec des lanceurs
d'alerte, avec des enfin des gens milieu
très différents, économistes, politique,
journaliste,
on n pas forcément une idée très précise
mais on se met en contact, on partage
des idées et
voilà. Et
tu arrives à dormir ? Oui oui oui oui.
Alors pas hier soir parce qu'il y a eu
du bazar dans le bâtiment mais sinon oui
je dors très bien. Pas de problème avec
ça.
C'est c'estd que tu anticipes un un choc
économique sur un système hypertendu.
Tu as je pense les capacités cognitives
de comprendre les implications que ça va
générer sur nos semblables et tu arrives
à dormir.
Oui. Bah oui.
C'est quoi ta drogue ? Alors, j'ai pas
de drogue. Euh bah non, c'est l'amitié,
c'est les livres, c'est le jardin, c'est
la famille. Euh
méditation.
Oui aussi un petit peu. Enfin bon, je
suis euh là je fais je te parle de Marc
Orel mais il y a Ouais, je j'essaie de
faire tu vois 10 minutes par jour où je
me balade à Besançon. Tu as plein de
encore avant à Bac avant la bétonisation
des vêtes. Il y a encore
on le passe le bonjour.
Voilà. Ouais. Alors, passe le bonjour
aux amis Bisantin.
C'est c'est on va poser une question
pour C'est c'est le dou ou la Franche
Comptée ?
C'est c'est alors c'est dans le dou et
c'est la Franche Comptée. Oui,
ça va.
Ouais, quand même. Non, pas faut pas
déconner. Et euh voilà, donc il y a Non,
méditation. Bon, ça veut tout dire, rien
dire. Pour moi, c'est tu vois genre se
balader 10 minutes dans la nature,
penser à rien.
Euh voilà, c'est
Franche Compté, tu as beaucoup de
chance. C'est quand même une région
magnifique de doux.
Oui, c'est sûr. Voilà. Donc c'est
d'autant plus pour ça que moi je je suis
donc la Zad qui est en train de se
créer. Je soutiens cette Zad et j'irai
me mettre s'il faut devant les les
tracteurs.
Pourquoi tu soutiens ?
Bah je soutiens parce que les 34
hectares intramuros de Besançon
donc de de de ce qui qui s'appelle les
vettes qui a un lieu de de verdure de de
de qui était où il y a aussi des jardins
partagés.
Euh ben j'ai pas envie que ça soit qu'il
y ait 24 hectares sur ces 34 qui soient
bétonnés, qu'on mette une route à double
sens dessus, qu'on mette 2000 m² de de
commerce dedans et que ça soit un
endroit de bobo gentrifié et puis que
les autres n'aient pas le droit de
rentrer dedans si tu veux et puis qu'il
y ait plus de jardin à partager. Donc ça
ça c'est niet. C'est et je peux dire
qu'on pacifiquement on fera tant euh que
ça soit avec extinction rébellion ou
avec euh
avec euh COP 21 action pacifique COP 21
on ira jusqu' et l'association des
jardins des bêtes, on ira jusqu'au bout.
Ça c'est clair. Alors on a déjà ils ont
déjà fait des actions juridiques,
ils ont gagné en première instance.
La ville va au Conseil d'État mais je
veux dire quelle que soit la décision,
on ira jusqu'au bout. Ça c'est clair.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses d'extinction
rébellion ? Moi, j'en pense rien. C'est
des Moi, je te dis, je parle marche par
amitié. C'est-à-dire que les les euh les
gens abes besançons qui sont
d'extinction rébellion, ce sont des
amis. Euh voilà, c'est tout ce que je
peux te dire. Euh
est-ce qu'il te ils te considèrent comme
un infiltré ? Est-ce que ils ont des
doutes sur toi parce que tu as travaillé
euh pour la DGSE ? Non, non, non, non,
non. Il y a pas de souci de ce côté-là.
Il y a pas de doute ou de quoi que ce
soit.
Tes adites, ils sont aussi gentils que
les adites de Notre Dame Land
parce que eux, il étaient sacrément
sympas.
Bah disons, ben il y a mon frère qui a
fait une petite vidéo qu'il a posté sur
sur son Facebook de de média qu'on a
qu'on a cofondé enfin qui qui gère qui
s'appelle le compost et on voit qu'il y
a toute une stratégie de de pacifique.
Justement, les policiers sont arrivés,
il y a eu de de de de fourgonnettes de
de policiers qui sont venus dernièrement
et il y a toute une stratégie, un
entraînement qui est fait pour bah se
laisser tomber lourdement pour tu vois
rester sur le lieu être pas tu vois
quand les policiers du mal à te retirer
du lieu mais tout en disant qu'on que ce
qu'on fait on le fait pour les enfants
des policiers. Tu vois, on n'est pas
dans il y a pas une démarche de
violence. Il y a pas une agressivité
contre la police. On leur en veut pas.
C'est pas violent de pénétrer sur un
aéroport parce que imagine-toi, je suis
pilote, j'ai un A 320 derrière moi avec
350 passagers
et je vois des gars se balader avec des
fumigèes, des vélos et je peux me dire
moi en tant que pilote qu'il y en a un
qui va me sortir un lance-roquette
antichar et qui va me viser au
décollage.
Non non non,
pourquoi non ? Non.
Ah non, pas ça. Non, non.
Pourquoi pas ça ?
Ouais, je pense pas dans les gens que je
fréquente. Je pense pas.
Non, mais en tant que pilote.
Ah ah, mais il peut imaginer ce qu'il
veut le pilote. Mais c'est dans dans sa
tête.
Violent, c'est violent. Oui, il a des
choses plus violentes quand même dans la
vie hein.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Oui, bien sûr. Non, non, je pour
l'instant je pense que là tu fais
vraiment le super avocat du diable parce
que non non, tu veux continue un peu
plus hein. Si, admettons, je pense que
il y en a un qui se balade avec un vélo
sur le tarmac et alors d'ailleurs on s
on se demande comment le vélo est arrivé
sur le tarmac. Il se dit tiens, il va me
prendre l'idée de le balancer dans le
réacteur de l'avion histoire de calmer
l'avion parce queen fait les avions
j'aime pas ça. Je me fais le super avocé
à lui dire.
D'accord.
Est-ce que tu peux te rendre compte du
niveau de stress ? Bah du personnel
navigant. Je suis d'accord. niveau de
stress de des gars qui vont se faire
virer parce qu'ils se sont fait peine
tester par trois pelos qui ont réussi à
passer avec un vélo.
Tu peux te rendre compte ?
Oui oui.
Est-ce que Extinction Rébillon comprend
qu'il y a des gens qui vont perdre leur
travail à cause de ça ?
Alors je veux pas parler en leur nom je
mais je je pense que les gens les amis
que je enfin les gens que je côtoie je
pense qu'ils comprennent les enjeux. Oui
effectivement mais je veux pas parler en
leur nom. Et après je te dis je euh
est-ce que tu penses qu'on devrait payer
extinction rébellion ? payé
parce qu'ils ont à peine testé notre
aéroport et qu'on s'est rendu compte que
quatre pelos avec des fumigènes un vélo
quatre pelos motivés dans un dans un
dans dans sur une sur une planète où on
a de moins en moins de gens qui sont
motivés et enfin j'exagère
l'enthousiasme fait tout dans la vie la
foi tout. Euh tu as pas besoin de moyens
euh si tu as la foi, tu peux tu peux
faire beaucoup de choses.
L'action sort du rêve.
Oui. Ou ou exactement.
Donc là-dessus, alors ça veut pas dire
je soutiens forcément tout ce que fait
Extinction. Moi je te parle de la de la
Z qui est en train de se créer à
Besançon. Là-dessus, je la soutiens à
100 %. Ça c'est clair.
Est-ce que tu soutiens Extinction
Rébillon ?
Dans l'absolu, je je sais pas. Je je
connais pas ce qui se passe au niveau
international. Je tu vois, je je voilà,
je peux pas j'ai pas de connaissance
là-dessus. En tout cas, au niveau local,
il y a pas de souci. Je suis avec eux.
Question d'internet. Peut-on parler de
réelles avancées dans la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale ? Les paradis fiscaux
n'ont-ils pas toujours un coup d'avance
?
Alors euh alors je veux pas dire oui
non, mais je suis quand même tenté. Euh
ils ont un il y a il y a là-dessus, je
reprends ce qu'a dit lors de l'athlé
économiste, on a quand même un un bon
côté, c'est que le l'Europe est de plus
en plus sensible à la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale et le CDE. Par contre,
on a des gens qui continuent de tricher
ouvertement. Luxembourg, Irlande,
Pays-Bas, Malte et cetera. Des
preuves de tout ça ?
Ben, je te parlais par exemple de de
voilà du de la de du soci le véhicule
d'investissement qui passait sous le
radar. Donc euh voilà. Après, c'est
vrai, c'est une question politique une
fois de plus. C'est-à-dire que c'est les
politiques, alors pas tous, on va pas
tous les mettre dans le même sac, mais
je pense à Junker et toute sa bande et
voilà.
Il y a aussi moi, il y a des choses
aussi qui me questionnent quand je vois
Moskovici qui dit queil y a pas de pays
enfin qu'il y a pas de paradis fiscaux
en Europe. Il me fait rire quoi. Enfin,
je comprends pas trop le bonhomme quoi.
Tu vois donc le la ils ont dans l'absolu
ils ont pas un coup d'avance. C'est
parce que tu as des gens à la tête des
institutions qui leur laissent avoir les
coups d'avance. En réalité, c'est très
simple. On pourrait arrêter l'évasion
fiscale très rapidement.
Alors euh c'est pas si c'est une
question. Sachant que la diffamation
Alors je je je mets pas en doute la
question mais j'ai pas creusé. Sachant
que la diffamation concerne n'importe
quel propos vérifiable pouvant nuire à
l'honneur
exactement
personne voilà de la personne qu'il soit
sourcé ou non comment le fait d'avoir
des sources protégerait de la
diffamation puisque ça tout à fait
porte
quand même atteinte à l'honneur loi du
pas tout à fait là-dessus déjà en fait
c'est la la façon dont on parle et dont
on écrit un article c'est le niveau de
modération première chose. Ensuite,
c'est est-ce qu'on est allé demander aux
personnes, aux acteurs ? On les a tenu
au courant de l'investigation. C'est le
cas. Moi, dans mon article, je
j'incrimine pas de mususe vie ou je je
je dis pas mon avis. D'ailleurs, j'en ai
pas si tu veux. Je donne que des faits.
Donc, il faut être neutre. Moi, je suis
neutre avec eux. Donc, quand tu es
neutre, que tu mets des éléments
factuels elle la personne qui envoie
cette question a absolument raison. La
diffamation, c'est pas le fait de dire
n'importe quoi. Euh, tu peux très bien
dire une information totalement juste,
mais si tu l'as dit d'une certaine
façon, tu peux t'attaquer et
potentiellement perdre dans un procès.
Même si tu as raison.
Même si tu as raison. Et ça, on on le
sait pas forcément le où on l'oublie.
Euh et le grand public ne le sait pas
forcément. Moi, je le savais pas il y a
encore quelques années tout.
Que pensent-t-il de l'influence des
grands pontes du journalisme français ?
Exemple le monde fit Xavier Niel.
Les les pontes ils appellent il c'est ça
en gros en gros qu'est-ce que tu penses
du fait que nos groupes de presse soient
détenus par des milliardaires ?
Qu'est-ce que j'en pense ? Ben j'en
pense c'est que stratégiquement super
quoi pour ce qu'ils font pour eux.
C'est-à-dire
enfin c'est ironique he évidemment c'est
euh
voilà c'est une façon de
justement pour ne pas être dans la
diffamation de de peser euh dans le
rapport de force avec les les
gouvernants. Euh voilà, sans en dire
plus que ça. Après moi je sans être
contre ces ces médias mainstream parce
qu'il y a plein de gens très bien dans
ces médias mainstream
et c'est vrai
et c'est vrai franchement là je tu vois
ils sont pas nombreux
non mais il y en a non mais c'est pas
qu' non c'est qu' il y en a moi je vois
je peux d'ailleurs donner les les noms
des médias je vois à Challange il y a
des gens super cap à
la croix la croix aussi
à la croix il y a des gens supers euh
libération
à la libération et tout ça
à BFM
euh même à BFM en grattant on devrait en
trouver un ou deux une ou deux
plus peut-être.
J'exagère, je suis méchant. Euh,
d'ailleurs, je profite de rebondir
là-dessus. J'avais quand même sorti une
investigation sur BFM TV et la remontée
de profit de Next Radio TV vers le
Luxembourg. ce qui était légal à
l'époque. Alors, il son euh ce qui était
légal euh on a eu alors l'investigation
que j'ai faite euh c'est une double
investigation parce que moi à l'origine
quand j'étais à Jersy déjà,
j'administrais le fond qui détenait un
pourcentage dans Ex Radio TV qui possède
voilà c'est donc moi j'étais déjà
derrière j'administrais le truc euh
j'étais le petit gras de papier mais
donc j'avais déjà cette partie de
l'histoire et ensuite il faut savoir que
en 2015
euh il y a si je dis pas de bêtises 2015
il y a Drahi qui est qui est arrivé et
et qui a racheté les parts de de ce que
possédait le fond dans Exradio TV déjà
en étant minoritaire ensuite en 2018 ou
2017 en étant majoritaire avec Altis
mais il y avait déjà un schéma à
l'origine depuis des années en fait Next
Radio TV BFM TV a été créé grâce à
l'argent des paradis fiscaux à l'origine
déjà c'est ce que je montrais dans
l'investigation et ensuite l'argent
repartait les profits déjà il y a il y a
très longtemps vers les paradis fiscaux
via le les pays et ensuite Jersey. Et
ensuite il y a Drake qui est rentré dans
la dans la course et euh
et ensuite c'est remonté vers Luxembourg
et vers la Suisse à travers une dizaine
de sociétés coquila. Il y en avait un
pas qui est Altis machin tuc tuc tuc.
Voilà. Euh et sauf que il remontait cet
argent. Alors il remonte de de façon il
y a il y a aussi l'argent de la
structure la coquille enfin de la
holding de dans laquelle il y a
libération tout ça mais bon je vais pas
forcément parler aujourd'hui et il y a
celle qui était extrêmement rentable. en
train d'enquêter, c'est ça ?
Bah disons, il se peut très bien que je
je repasse un coup de de
Ripolin de Ripolin dessus quoi. Et euh
donc sur BFM TV, donc Next Radio TV, tu
as tu as tout cet argent qui remonte à
travers
à travers un un prêt participatif. Et
justement dans l'investigation, Yanis
Mamdi avec qui j'avais fait enfin qui
avait mis en forme l'investigation avait
interviewé en revient encore au syndicat
majoritaire de Bery euh donc finance
solidaire public. Donc c'était
secrétaire national euh
Vincent Dreuset qui avait expliqué ce
que c'était qu'un un prêt participatif
et que c'était souvent utilisé pour
faire du du blanchiment et et de la
fraude fiscale. Euh voilà. Et je crois
aussi dernièrement, alors c'est pas lié
à mon investigation, mais que
le groupe a eu euh des problèmes avec le
fils, enfin, il y a eu une voilà, il y a
eu un
des explications.
Il y a eu des explications, voilà.
Pas des problèmes
des Pardon, excuse-moi, je cherchais mes
mots d'une explication.
Voilà. Euh voilà,
question d'in Internet.
Est-ce qu'il a un plan de retraite
retraite et quel est-il ? Quelle est la
proportion de votre patrimoine dans la
bourse ? Répartition, action,
obligation.
Mort de rire là. Alors euh dans la
bourse, j'ai jamais super GG, je te
remercie déjà. J'ai jamais acheté une
action de ma vie déjà pour commencer,
j'ai pas de plan retraite. Je vis
simplement, j'ai une petite maison dans
les Vauges avec un terrain de 7000 m²,
un grand verger et du potager et c'est
tout. Et une maisonnette.
Est-ce que tu as peur pour nos retraites
?
Non. Ah pour nos retraites ? Pour ma
retraite, non, mais pour nos retraite,
bah dans l'absolu, oui, si tout
s'effondre, je pense qu'il y a même le
l'idée même de retraite, le concept même
de retraite va devoir être sans doute
enfin c'est une probabilité repenser
quoi.
Enfin, je sais pas, j'ai pas réfléchi en
détail, je coulerait de source.
Alors, autre question internet, bougez
pas, on va piocher.
Alors, GG, on l'a fait.
Ouais. Oui, on va vite.
Alors ça c'est une affirmation.
D'accord. Il cherche à détruire mais
dans quel but ? Je sais pas si ça peut
être une question pour toi
de détruire.
Alors est-ce que tu as Question d'orange
est-ce que tu en as pas marre d'être
pauvre ? Mais
je suis pas pauvre. Je me sens pas
pauvre en fait.
Je je je mange correctement, je vis très
correctement. J'ai les choses dont j'ai
besoin. Euh,
vous voyez pas ce qu'il fait derrière.
Euh euh non, je vis très moi je me sens
extrêmement riche, il y a pas de souci.
Je je me sens dans l'abondance, il y a
pas de problème.
Et je tiens à préciser que je n'ai pas
de voiture et que j'ai un vélo et que je
et que j'utilise les transports en
commun et que ça me va très bien.
C'est quoi être riche ?
et riche euh bah c'est je pense euh
avoir un toit euh avoir de quoi manger
et puis dans avoir suffisamment chaud et
sentir en sécurité. C'est ça être riche.
Non,
être heureux.
Alors heureux euh moi c'est un un
concept alors moi je me sens heureux si
tu veux mais c'est un concept aussi euh
je suis pas trop certain du truc.
J'aurais tendance à dire vaut mieux être
conscient qu'heureux parce que dans ta
vie tu seras toujours à un moment donné
malheureux. Tu as toujours un être cher
qui va disparaître. Il y aura peut-être
de la maladie, il y aura donc il y aura
toujours du malheur à un moment donné,
mais si tu es conscient, ben tu vis avec
ces ces moments-là quoi. Si
je te dit heureux les simples d'esprit,
aujourd'hui j'ai compris.
Oui. Qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
C'est pour ça à quoi ?
Euh je sais pas, j'en sais rien.
[__] pourtant ça fait 2000 ans que
c'était c'était
Ah oui, Jésus. Oui, bah Jésus-Christ.
Oui, super. Désolé. Oui.
Alors, question. Combien de temps vont
durer ses connaissances, ses contacts
pour rester un lanceur d'alerte ?
Mais tu sais, lanceur d'alerte, c'est
euh c'est qu'une étiquette. Je veux
dire, quelque part euh
comment dire ? Moi je
quelque part si on garde bien, je
préfère ne pas me définir du tout. C'est
ce qui permet de en fait de d'aller un
peu partout.
Euh je suis rentré dans la finance sans
être un financier. Je suis rentré dans
le monde du renseignement sans être issu
du serrail. Je suis rentré dans le monde
ser
bah disons je je suis pas un gars qui
qui qui était dans le ministère de dans
le ministère de la défense. Je suis pas
un gars de l'armée. Je suis pas j'ai pas
été formé pour ça si tu veux. Je suis
rentré dans le monde de journalisme
comme ça mais je suis pas journaliste.
Pourtant tu as une tête de bidasse hein.
C'est
ouais si tu veux. Euh ensuite
euh ouais, il y a j'ai toujours aimé
écrire mais voilà, j'ai sorti un livre
et je pense j'en sortirai d'autres mais
je me considère pas non plus comme
écrivain pour autant. À partir du moment
où on se met une étiquette pour en venir
à la question de lanceur d'alerte,
lancer euh on reste cloisonné, on reste
enfermé. Alors pourquoi pas ? Oui,
lanceur d'alerte sur effectivement sur
j'ai lancé l'alerte avec mon livre, je
continue de lancer l'alerte avec mes
investigations et en partageant ces
alertes avec le grand public et avec des
politiques pour voir ce qui ce qui peut
être fait. Euh mais ça aussi aura une
fin évidemment.
Alors, en tant qu'ancienne source de la
DGSE, peut-il nous par je je complète la
question. Peut-il nous parler des
cryptoonnaies ?
Non, j'ai aucune connaissance dessus
donc ça serait risible. Euh
est-ce que la DGSE tu as déjà posé des
questions sur les cryptomonnaies ?
Non non non non, j'avais même je savais
même pas que ça existait en 2012. Donc
euh tu vois, j'étais hasbine là-dessus.
Euh j'aimerais juste excuse euh tout à
l'heure euh alors peut-être là c'est
vraiment passé du Coocalan, mais pour
revenir un peu euh on a euh à concernant
l'investigation, suite à la sortie de
l'investigation que j'ai faite pour le
média sur les épades et les assurances
vies, euh donc il y a deux députés euh
donc Hugo Bernalici et Fabien Roussel et
Fabien Roussell a déposé ou va déposer,
j'étais en contact avec
son assistant parlementaire Laurent
Vattier va déposer une demande
d'information information
attends comment s'appelle une mission
d'information sur la gestion des
assurances et des assurances. Donc je
serai sans aucun doute auditionné. Euh
donc ça aussi c'est un de mes buts,
c'est-à-dire que euh mon but c'est de
sortir des informations pour le grand
public sur des choses qui me semblent
euh importante et qui a un relais
politique euh et puis aussi de temps en
temps de mener des actions juridiques.
Alors je sais pas si on en parlera mais
voilà quoi.
Est-ce que tu as vu le papier des échos
qui dit exclusif le Bitcoin est
désormais a désormais sa place dans les
contrats d'assurance vie ?
Non j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas lu ça.
Non non moi je me suis plus spécifié
alors c'est super. Je vais regarder
après. Je te remercie. Je remercie la
personne. J'ai plus regardé sur les
sociétés euh
coquille, les qui sont dans les paradis
fiscaux et les les et les
investissements qui qui sont réalisés
par la suite. Mais j'ai pas encore
regardé au niveau des Bitcoin.
Alors, question de lanterne, quit des
malversations fiscales dans les univers
des start-ups. Est-ce que le mythe des
licornes et des startup nation est un
écran de fumée pour des montages fiscaux
du entre virgule du blanchiment d'argent
?
Tu as pas enquêté donc du
Non, j'ai pas enquêté donc je là j'ai
des amis qui m'en ont parlé mais je tant
que je me suis pas mis sur le dossier,
je préfère pas en parler.
Alors là, j'ai un commentaire qui je
vais te le lire, tu vas peut-être
réagir. Alors, c'est inexact. que
l'argent ne peut pas sortir vers un fond
de placement à risque sans que ce soit
transparent pour le détenteur de
l'assurance vie et ces fonds qui ne
représente que 3 6 9 100 milliards
d'euros à Jersy dont le seulement une
infime partie ne publie pas d'état
financier et même si c'est le cas AXA a
évidemment accès aux investissements du
fond. Bah, pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
eu la réponse à la question très simple
qui était posée dans les emails que je
leur envoyé ? Et d'autre part, il y a
pas que Gersety, il y a Garneus, il y a
Luxembourg et il y a plein d'autres
paradis fiscaux qui sont utilisés.
La majorité des placements des
assurances VI en unité de compte, y
compris ceux qui investissent dans les
fonds étrangers. 36.
C'est intéressant de savoir qui c'est
qui envoie le
Ouais. Ouais. D'actifs sous gestion au
Luxembourg investissent dans des fonds
où il y a une obligation rigoureuse de
publication financière. Bien sûr, bien
sûr. Vespasien.
Mais bien sûr Vespasien, c'est Bien sûr
que non puisque d'après tous les
documents que je vois, il y a aucune
information sur les investissements qui
sont faits. Donc bien sûr que non.
Est-ce que tu as pas vu les bons
documents ?
Ah bien sûr. Oui oui, c'est sûr qu'à
Jersin, on m'a donné les documents pour
savoir où était placé l'argent des
assurances vies.
Alors
question. Alors ça ça fait plusieurs
fois que je vois passer, je connais pas
mais je vais la lire quand même.
Pourquoi la France ne parle pas du
scandale wire card et de la fraude à 2
milliards d'euros ? Point
d'interrogation, c'est une question. Je
ne sais pas s'il y a eu fraude et je ne
sais pas si c'est 2 milliards d'euros.
Tu as entendu parler de ça ?
Oui, mais c'est pareil. J'ai lu vite
fait deux trois articles. Je je peux je
peux pas te dire en particulier. Moi, je
préfère vraiment à chaque fois parler de
des investigations que je fais en long
l'argent en travers.
Mais ça c'est quelque part c'est un peu
potentiellement un symptôme avant la
crise si tu veux. Tu sais, c'est genre
un petit peu les cadavres qui commencent
à sortir de euh des armoires avant avant
que la crise arrive. Tu vois c'est pas
anodin quoi. C'est pas
comme en automne.
C'est c'est
Ouioui, c'est ça exactement.
Et le livret a même punition point
interrogation.
Je là je peux pas te dire je
Est-ce que tu as jamais enquêté sur le
livra ?
Non, je pas regarder. Non.
Crypto futur monnaie. Qu'est-ce que tu
penses de la BCE ?
La BCE qui pensait à acheter des
actions, il en pense quoi
là ? C'est pareil, j'en pense je pense
que il retarde la crise si tu veux.
C'est ils retardent la crise et ils vont
la rendre.
Il retarde ou il gagne du temps.
Bah ça dépend de si tu vois le la moitié
du verre, s'il est rempli ou voilà. Mais
c'est important.
OK. Euh
il la retarde. OK. Il la retarde. Ils
font avec les moyens. Alors si on est
bienveillant, on va dire qu'ils font
avec les moyens du bord.
Il faut toujours être bienveillant.
Ouais, il faut toujours être
bienveillant. Tu as raison. Exactement.
Alors ça
alors mais bon en même temps ils font
avec les moyens du bord mais on pourrait
faire sûrement autrement parce que aussi
le risque en faisant ce qu'ils font à
l'heure actuelle c'est qu'ils aggravent
la risque le le ils aggravent la crise
en injectant en injectant les les des
des centaines de milliards d'euros et en
rachetant des actifs comme ça en créant
des bulles. Donc il y a si tu veux ils
font de leur mieux mais je suis pas sûr
que qu' que ça soit vraiment aidant
quoi. Alors question : "Est-ce que tu
t'es intéressé au financement de
extinction rébellion ?" Et j'en profite
pour répondre à vos race. On ne dit plus
la nuit du HAC, on dit le HAC
maintenant. Donc le financement
d'extinction rébellon, ça tuas tu as
cherché.
C'est c'est pour ça ? Ouais. Non, c'est
pour ça que je te disais que je voulais
pas en parler au niveau international
parce que je ne sais pas s'il y a des
quels sont les financements au niveau
international. C'est pour ça que je
disais à chaque fois moi je veux je
parle vraiment de de de des choses que
je connais que je enfin je maîtrise un
minimum. Au niveau local, je vois les
personnes. Au niveau international, euh
peut-être, j'en sais rien. Je je ne sais
pas qui sont les financiers ou pas de de
ce groupement.
Alors question Syerview. Pouvez-vous lui
demander s'il connaît Iscandar Safa et
Privin Vest. Il y a eu une affaire jugée
par le DOJ américain cet hiver. Possible
tentative de rachat d'un groupe du
chantival français.
On laisse
privest. Oui, je je connais mais j'ai
j'ai plus ça en tête. Euh
si tu veux, on peut repartir parce que
là j'ai un peu peur de tu vois de ça va
être des questions, je vais dire non, je
connais pas ou je maîtrise pas ou
c'est pas grave.
C'est pas OK.
Quelques chiffres pour résumer l'ampleur
de l'évasion fiscale.
Ah oui, alors bah déjà c'est alors il y
a deux types de chiffres. Il y a déjà
les fraudes euh qui sont différentes de
l'évasion fiscale. Et là, le syndicat
finances publique solidaire est d'accord
pour une fourchette minimale d'ailleurs
qui a été recoupée par la
euh par la comment s'appelle
? J'ai oublié le nom de cette instance,
la la Cour des comptes qui a au minimum
80 milliards en France de fraudes qui
qui sont faites et là c'est en dehors de
l'évasion fiscale. l'évasion fiscale ce
minimum 100 milliards d'euros mais
personne n'arrive pour l'instant vra
véritablement
à à comptabiliser ces
les fraudes
ou l'optimisation
ou l'optim alors là l'optimisation c'est
encore l'optimisation fiscale agressive
là c'est voilà tu es encore un trisème
tu ouvre un trème compartiment
alors question de yanou est-ce que le
green deal européen pourrait aider
l'Union européenne à amortir le choc de
la prochaine crise financière et il nous
envoie un papier du monde. Ursula Ven,
un Green Deal européen.
Alors là, ralentir
là déjà qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que le Green
Deal, qu'est-ce qu'il y aura dedans ?
Alors, potentiellement, enfin faut voir
là, c'est pas j'ai pas lu ce qu'il y
avait dans dans ce Green Deal, mais je
me méfie énormément, même si je me sens
écolo dans l'âme, je me je me méfie
énormément d'étiquette Green Deal, écolo
et tout ça. Je reviens encore au niveau
local à Besançon. Tu vois, c'est une mer
écolo qui passe et on va avoir une Zade
euh parce que il va avoir une
bétonisation d'un lieu. Donc Green Deal,
ça prend avec des pincettes que si c'est
pour nous refaire des énormes travaux
qui vont servir à rien. Euh
voilà, c'est c'est vu d'avance quoi.
On connaît déjà la réponse mais on va la
poser quand même. L'arcemporain et le
fisque en France. Point d'interrogation.
Oui, bah c'est un super moyen de faire
l'évasion fiscale. Ouais, ça c'est sûr.
Tu as tuachètes un surtout l'art
contemporain parce que en fait quand
c'est pas de l'art contemporain, quand
c'est de l'art euh classé, je sais plus
comment ça s'appelle, euh tu peux pas le
sortir du pays comme ça, c'est
compliqué. Par contre, le gros avantage
de l'art contemporain, tu peux le
l'envoyer où tu veux. Euh donc
l'idéal, si tu es riche, c'est d'avoir
une galerie d'art parce que tu vas être
défiscalisé à fond. c'est de vendre de
l'art, de te racheter de l'art et puis
après bah de de bah de sortir ça, de
l'amener en Suisse dans les dans les
ports francs là-bas. Donc oui, c'est un
moyen énorme de faire d'évasion fiscale.
Alors, question de d'Artémis. Quel job
conseillerait-il conseillerais-tu aux
jeunes qui se lancent dans la vie ?
Alors, de job, non, là la pour moi, je
dirais quel est votre à un jeune, quel
est votre désir vraiment ? Quelle est la
la chose qui vous me euh moi je partirai
du désir avant de me dire quel est le
l'emploi. L'emploi c'est vraiment c'est
comme une étiquette, c'est pareil, tu la
trouves mais c'est vraiment quel est ton
désir ?
Question DLESC des solutions concrètes
contre l'évasion fiscale.
Alors il y en a plusieurs qui sont
conseillés par des gens comme d'ailleurs
Anlor de Latou Piketti et Zman, donc des
économistes français qui sont connus
internationalement. déjà un cadastre de
un cadastre financier pour savoir où
sont les actifs déjà international pas
que pas que les actifs français la
première chose ça paraît tout simple
mais c'est la moindre des choses.
Ensuite c'est qui est il y aurait un
tout simplement un prélèvement à la
source bah comme pour c'est plus je
dirais le PC qui qui Fabien Rousel qui
avait cette idée là euh mais pourquoi ne
pas avoir le prélèvement à la source
pour les entreprises ?
Après, il il y a plein d'autres choses.
Il y a il y a plein d'autres moyens. Il
y a aussi justement de la vision
conférence que j'ai faite, il y avait
Hugo Bernal ici qui était plus sur le
fait de
taxe
non de
tu sais que le en fait l'évasion fiscale
ou le ou le l'optimisation fiscale c'est
un abus de droit aussi en fait. l'ab de
droit, il est il est le comment la loi
est est pas assez dense d'une certaine
façon et Hig Bernalici proposait de la
la rendre plus dense pour caractériser
avoir plus de moyens de caractériser un
abus droit pour être plus pour attaquer
plus facilement les les gens qui
fraudent. Donc ça c'est encore une autre
idée. Dans la visioconférence aussi, on
se disait que le renseignement pouvait
aider, ce qui est pas le cas, en tout
cas pas suffisamment aider à à lutter
contre le l'évasion fiscale puisqu'on
faut
les Américains,
voilà par exemple. Bon sans sans les
copier, mais euh on on
Pourquoi sans les copier ? Ça a l'air de
fonctionner non ?
Ouais ouais je sais pas moi, c'est pas
un pays qui qui m'enchante trop. C'est
pas c'est pas des modèchant pas trop.
C'est pas c'est pas
Tu connais les États-Unis ? Ouais, j'y
suis allé trois fois et à chaque fois je
me suis allé où ça
alors pas pas longtemps, je suis bien
d'accord hein. Alors, je suis allé à
Chicago
deux fois et euh une fois New York.
Chicago, c'est une super ville.
Oui. Oui. Non mais les Américains, le
j'adore mais je veux dire les instances
de direction, euh je veux dire les
politiques là-bas, c'est c'est des gens
qui les systèmes en place, les pouvoirs
en place m'intéressent pas. C'est
c'est voilà. Mais après, c'est un peuple
qui est qui est qui qui est très
intéressant euh par plein d'aspects
évidemment, mais bon qui attaque comme
chacun sait notre souveraineté euh tous
les jours cordialement. Donc j'ai j'ai
pas d'antipathie mais j'ai pas voilà je
je suis pas extrêmement intéressé par ce
genre de de pays.
S'inspirer de leur méthode du
renseignement pour aller serrer ceux qui
font euh pas les choses correctement. Je
sais pas parce que je je pas trop
l'impression qu'il a une éthique
extrêmement développée. Donc non, c'est
pas c'est pas des gens qui m'inspiraient
y compris pour développer une meilleure
façon de de de renseigner.
C'est quoi l'éthique de la DGSE ?
Je peux ça c'est alors tu devrais leur
demander.
Tu leuras posé la question ?
Non. Ah non.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'il manque
d'éthique ?
Euh c'est c'est pas moi de
Est-ce que l'arme doit avoir Est-ce que
l'arme doit avoir une éthique ? Est-ce
que comment
est-ce que l'arme doit avoir une éthique
?
L'arme euh bah oui, évidemment. Sinon
euh tu tu t'ouvres tu t'ouvres le tu
t'ouvres à des à des violences à des
coups d'état
des coups d'état et à la barbarie tout
simplement. À la barbarie.
Euh en tout cas pour en revenir à
C'est quoi l'éthique de la DGSE ?
l'éthique de la DGE, c'est c'est pas moi
de la définir. En tout cas, peut-être
qu'un jour on aura la définir en tant
que peuple souverain, mais pour
l'instant, c'est voilà, c'est pas
J'aimerais bien qu'on soit un peuple qui
on puisse la définir ensemble.
Et ce qui serait bien aussi, c'est que
on arrête qui a toujours ce ce comment
dire ce ce parallèle. Il y a l'État et
nous, moi je considère qu'on est l'État.
Bon, simplement, malheureusement
structurellement
euh on peut pas agir comme étant l'État,
mais ça serait bien qu'un jour il y a un
changement qui soit fait sur peut-être
avec la crise, ça va être le bon côté de
la crise à mon avis, c'est que il va
avoir des changements structurels très
importants qui vont être faits
obligatoirement. C'est
tu entends changement structurel, tu
entends Atlas Saxis sectionné et je
roule par terre ou
non ? Non, non. Je veux dire où euh où
où les gens où on a une démocratie
vraiment
bon sans tomber dans sans tomber dans
des éléments de langage mais vraiment
participatif quoi véritablement.
Là-dessus, les Suisses pour le coup
m'intéressent plus euh plus que les
Américains. En tout cas, pour la façon,
je dis pas que c'est parfait chez eux,
hein, c'est en terme en terme de
démocratie, mais il m'intéresse plus
plus envie de m'inspirer d'eux si tu
veux sur l'aspect cet aspect-l. Il y a
ton ami vespasien euh qui c'est pas il
revient pas à l'attaque, il n'attaque
pas. Il on va lire ce sa prose. Si une
compagnie euh comme Sy Cerview peut
investir l'argent de sa clientèle dans
un fond étranger, cela représente par
essence une fraction minime. 20 % des
polices sont en unité de compte et parmi
celle-ci, l'essentiel de
l'investissement concerne les actions et
les obligations et les fonds UCITS.
Le fond de placement privé sont
minoritaires et les personnes qui
souscrivent savent très bien à quoi
elles souscrivent. Si la compagnie
distribue directement un fond domicilié
à Gercer à sa clientèle, soit celle-ci
est considérée comme un investisseur
qualifié entre parenthèses
professionnell investisseur au-dessus de
500000 € et peut investir virtuellement
n'importe où, soit elle ne l'est pas et
le fond doit publier les deux la
documentation financière appropriée
conformément aux directives UCITS.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler des de la
directive UCITS ?
Euh non.
de
Ah, tu fais moins ton malin là ? Ouioui,
je fais moins mon malin. Je vais dire
pourquoi. Parce que pour moi c'est un
alors c'est très bien documenté, tout ce
que tu veux mais c'est une façon de
noyer le poisson une fois de plus pour
ne pas voir l'argent qui part dans les
paradis fiscaux et endormir. Et ça c'est
pour moi c'est le alors merci Vespasien
mais c'est le le discours classique
qu'on entend de nos politiques et qui
nous endorme avec des trucs technocrates
qui ne veulent absolument rien dire pour
essayer de nous perdre dans des choses
pseudo compliquées alors qu'elles sont
très simples. Et moi mon travail à
chaque fois c'est de voir les flux
financiers de façon très précise, très
documentée avec les informations de
l'intérieur de ces structures.
De montrer, d'ailleurs, c'est pas moi
qui le montre, mais de dire quand il y a
des directives européennes qui disent
"Attention, là c'est illégal, illégal".
Voilà. Euh mais effectivement que tu as
une partie de de l'assurance vie qui va
être dans des dans dans
pardon de l' excuse-moi, commence à
avoir chaud là. fait très chaud euh
dans des des choses sécurisées au niveau
de l'État si tu veux, mais le jour où il
y aura la crise financière, même cet
argent qui sera sécurisé par l'État
volera en éclat, je veux dire et ça
viendra du fait de cet argent qui a été
placé offshore. Donc là, Vespasien, il
nous sort sa jaja technocratique. Merci.
Mais c'est une façon de mettre le
problème sous le sous le paillasson.
Euh et l'argent est offshore en partie
dans des structures totalement opaques
et les gens qui souscrivent je je le
redis les assurances vient pour la
immense majorité ne savent pas comment
leur argent est géré et s'ils le
savaient je pense qu'ils ne mettraient
pas leur argent dans les assurances vi
queles que soient les entreprises.
Question de euh est-il conscient de son
biais idéologique pour interrogation ?
Est-ce que tu penses avoir un biais
idéologique ?
Oui, j'ai un biais idéologique
évidemment. on en a tous un et c'est sûr
euh euh
je suis comme je le disais d'ailleurs je
m'en cache pas, je dis je suis plus
entre guillemets cataloguer gauche
radical euh que LRM, ça c'est évident.
Après, pour te donner un contreexemple,
j'ai été contacté il y a 2 jours par une
députée qui est anciennement LRM, qui
est anciennement aussi, qui est Frédéric
Duma qui m'a dit "Je souhaiterais, je je
suis très enthousiaste par votre
investigation et je souhaite je
souhaiterais donc" sur les épades et les
assurances vie et je souhaiterais euh
utiliser les termes qu'il y a dans votre
investigation avec votre accord pour les
mettre dans les publier dans le GIO pour
que le gouvernement réponde à ces
questions. Et moi, j'ai dit "Bien sûr."
Donc oui, j'ai j'ai un il y a un biais
politique en même temps. Tu vois bien
que par exemple quand alors que je suis
écolo quand tu as une mère de Besançon
qui estcolo qui me dit on va bétonner
les vêtes. Tu vois tout et euh
le biais aussi il est moi il est
un président de français qui dit mon
ennemi c'est la finance.
Voilà c'est ça si tu veux. Moi voilà
c'est dès que tu as quelqu'un qui
faut faire attendre. Moi je je suis
vraiment à nouveau le bon sens paysan
c'est voilà il y a la personne qui dit
une chose et comment elle met la chose
en pratique elle peut mettre n'importe
quelle étiquette qui paraît séduisante
pour moi au premier abord si derrière
elle fait totalement l'opposé alors
c'est clair que je vais pas être à ses
côtés c'est évident
alors on connaît pas le projet de
bétonnage comme tu nous le décris mais
on ira vo
question de oneel l'évasion fiscale
n'est-elle pas causée par la pression
fiscale
ouais
et tu comprends pourquoi je te pose
cette question parce que on doit avoir
double prisme de lectur
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça de cette
question là ?
Ben non, je pense que déjà l'évasion
Tu penses qu'en France on est trop taxé
?
Bah on est taxé de façon importante,
c'est sûr.
C'est quoi importante ?
Euh
le top 10 des pilers le plus taxé au
monde, on est quoi ?
Je peux pas te dire, je crois qu'on est
dans le top 3 ou top 5, je sais plus. Je
peux pas te dire là-dessus, mais on
l'est de façon importante. Mais aussi en
contrepartie, on a on a tellement de
services.
On a quoi ? des infirmières payé 1500 €
qui sont mal payés dans des é gens qui
font des photocopies à 6000 € par mois.
La tête de Ber oui par exemple non on a
on avait jusqu'à maintenant
la tête de Ber on sait pas si c'est la
tête de Bery
ouais on sait pas où elles sont
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas
non on a on avait un étage jusqu'il y a
ces dernières années qui marchait pas si
mal que ça bon après Macron voilà avec
sa bande il s'amuse à tout dynamiter.
Tant pis pour lui hein. Je veux dire
ça c'est ton point de vue.
C'est mon point de vue ouais.
Euh mais
euh non, je pense que oui, on paye des
impôts. Il y avait jusqu'à maintenant,
jusqu'il y a pas si longtemps que ça en
tout cas, il y avait des service en
échange et la France était connue dans
le monde pour pour voilà pour être
capable de délivrer des services à ses
citoyens. Euh ensuite effectivement là
où la question quelque part enfin c'est
extrêmement intéressant c'est
effectivement si on paye continue de
payer des impôts mais qu'on a de moins
en moins de services et que les gens qui
sont dans les services sont de moins en
moins bien payés et que ça devient des
contractuels qui sont effectivement là
on peut se poser la question est-ce que
ça aura encore un sens de payer des
impôts sachant qu'en plus ces impôts
sont payés pour par exemple payer des
structures qui dont les bénéfices vont
offshore. Donc là il y a une vraie
question c'est oui on paye des impôts.
Oui, c'est bien d'en payer pour avoir
des services, mais si c'est pour ne plus
avoir de services ou moins ou être que
les gens soient qui soient très mal payé
et et que l'argent par dans les paradis
fiscaux, oui, on peut se poser la
légitimité de payer des impôts.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire UCITS ?
Je peux même plus te le dire. J'ai su
tout ça mais voilà, c'est
Undertaking for collective investment
in transférable securit.
Tu je monque parce que j'ai cassé mon
masque.
Ah d'accord. OK. Je croyais que tu
allais grignoter quelque chose.
Désolé pour cette petite aparté.
Pas de souci.
Comme tu le remarques ici on est à
cheval sur les
les
Tu vi de recasser il vient de recasser
son deuxième masque là.
Si si il est pété. On s'en fout. Euh, on
va le maintenir avec la main. Euh, dans
quels paradis fiscaux vont les
milliardaires et les des les milliards
des dictateurs et des multinationales
africain
suisse. Suisse, suisse,
on parle souvent de la Suisseur.
Oui. Oui, encore et toujours. Oui,
encore et toujours.
Comment tu sais ça ? parce que j'ai je
dével grâce au livre une fois de plus en
fait, j'ai développé un réseau en Suisse
et là il est en train de remettre son
troisème masque et donc j'ai maintenant
un en fait j'ai j'ai des réseaux qui
sont en train de se développer en
Belgique, au Luxembourg, en en Suisse
qui sont des nouveaux réseaux qui
étaient qui étaient pas les réseaux que
j'avais déjà de de
de
mon passé dans la finance.
et ils sont en train de se frotter les
mains là. Voilà. Et euh
et donc oui, effectivement, j'ai des
informations de de la Suisse, de gens
qui sont très très bien informés, de
Suisse eux-mêmes et je suis très
content, je vais en voir prochainement
là.
Tu fais comment pour les protéger ces
gens-là ?
Disons qu'il y a des
disons Oui, enfin il y a jamais de c'est
eux qui me contactent, il y a des Ouais.
C'est des rencontres qui sont ou qui
vont se faire et la meilleure façon de
se protéger si tu veux, c'est de se
rencontrer dans des colloques où on est
plein ou dans des moyens tu vois des
tournés euh
les Russes ?
Je sais pas comment ils fonctionnent les
Russes
ou les Américains.
Ça y est, tu m' relances avec les
Américains. Donc voilà, mais il y a j'ai
voilà j'ai des très bons contacts et
amis en Suisse, au Luxembourg
et en Belgique depuis la sortie du du
livre.
Voilà, des nouveaux nouveaux contacts.
Alors euh je vais te poser encore deux
trois questions euh de de la communauté.
Que pensent-t-il du grand reset évoqué
par le FMI ?
Le grand reset c'est-à-dire voir
le FMI avait parlé de faire un reset de
l'économie ou qu'un grand reset, je sais
pas.
C'estàd d'annuler les dettes et toutes
ces choses-là ou
je sais pas.
Là je peux pas dire s'ils sont pas plus
précis. Euh
alors, que pensent-il du du capitalisme,
du communisme et de l'anarchie ?
Euh
bah c'est pareil en fait, j'ai pas de
j'ai pas de point de vue si tu veux dans
dans l'absolu parce que tout ça ce sont
des concepts et moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la mise en pratique et la la
faisabilité
d'une vie ensemble. On voit bien que le
communisme à l'étranger, ça a pas marché
du tout. Ça a été une horreur. Je dis ça
alors que je suis amis euh avec le le
PC, mais en tout cas en en dans l'Union
soviétique, ça a pas marché. Le
capitalisme ça a pas marché non plus. Ça
ne marche pas. Une destruction de la
planète, on va dans le mur, les
inégalités se creusent, donc ça ne
marche pas non plus. Euh l'anarchie euh
malheureusement a été très mal
documentée, mal connue jusqu'à peu
dévoyé. On se rend compte que
l'anarchie, c'est pas ce qu'on veut bien
croire. C'està dire, c'est pas forcément
un type qui balance une bombe sur
l'archiduc, voilà, de ce qui est pas
bien effectivement, mais c'est aussi il
y a eu deux excellents documentaires.
Ce n'est pas que les Black Block,
ce n'est pas que les Black Block, c'est
aussi les deux documentaires là de qui
ont été fait qui ont été superbement
bien documé Dramonais.
Voilà, exactement. Et on voit que il y
avait des des des gens qui ont pu vivre
ensemble dans des communautés autonomes.
Et ça ça m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse
en fait quel que soit le le l'étiquette
qu'on mette, c'est moi ce qui
m'intéresse qu'on soit droite, gauche,
gauche radicale, ce qui ce qui
m'intéresse ou ou écolo aussi ou ça
c'est est-ce qu'on est on arrive à vivre
ensemble même si on est en désaccord sur
sur certains sujets ? Est-ce qu'on
arrive à créer une communauté de
d'entente de l'entraide ? Euh
c'est ça qui m'importe véritablement.
Après le reste euh on sait que le le on
sait que le le capitalisme voilà c'est
si on continue comme ça dans dans on va
véritablement dans le mur, c'est sûr.
Alors je te fais une volée de question.
Euh quel pays pourvivre dans une
certaine justice fiscale et pourquoi
être simplement zen ? Peut-on vraiment
appliquer des réformes fiscales sur les
finances sans condamner les entreprises
françaises étant donné que le que la
finance est mondiale et qu'il est facile
d'aller voir ailleurs ?
Euh peut-on techniquement isoler et
soumettre un paradis fiscal ? Ouais, ça
c'est simple, on envoie les chars, il y
a pas de problème.
Donc il y a plein de questions là. Euh
disons,
peut-on soumettre un paradis fiscal ?
Oui.
Bon, j'aime pas trop l'idée de de
soumettre mais disons oui euh si on le
décidait en tant que citoyen, on
pourrait la France pourrait très bien
dire
on va dire le Luxembourg
non, on pourrait non, on pourrait très
bien dire un jour au Luxembourg suffit
maintenant vraiment vous arrêtez
et ils vont nous regarder, ils vont
sourire, vont faire c'est bien les gars.
Non non, on va on va leur demander de
rapatrier tous les fonds qu'on a chez
chez eux déjà chez nous pour commencer
et puis euh et après il y a plein de
d'autres outils juridique
potentiellement enfin qu'on peut faire
avec de la diplomatie plus active que
voilà assez active.
Mais il y a moyen de de de d'être actif
et de de d'avoir des mesures de
rétorsion pacifique et intelligentes si
tu veux.
Alors ça c'est une question très
intéressante. Macron Le Pen
quel vote ? Pourquoi ? Aucun des deux.
Tu votes de blanc ?
Ah, je vote de blanc. Oui. Aucun des
deux. Entre l'extrême centre et
l'extrême droite, aucun des deux. Aucun
ne m'intéresse. Et pour moi, c'est la
même chose. C'est pareil.
Ou là là, il y a Vespasien qui t'en met
une couche encore.
Ah oui, mais vas-y. Ouais,
je peux
ouis vas-y. Je juste dire je ne sais
pas, c'est tout. Mais
alors je n'ai pas lu le je n'ai pas lu
le message, mais on va le lire quand
même ensemble. Euh, ça n'engage que que
nous.
Il ne répond pas à la question en
m'accusant d'être un technocrate. n'est
pas du préchi précha, c'est un cadre
concret et réglementé à la fois par
l'autorité financière française et
domestique AMF pour la France CSS F pour
le Luxembourg et par les auditeurs du
fond en question Ey, PWC,
Mazar
de Load, Grand Torton, KPMG qui collecte
en plus les états financiers de chaque
fond dans lequel le produit de
l'assurance vie est placé par pour
effectuer une valorisation indépendante
du portefeuille. Ce n'est ce n'en est
rien opaque pour et ce n'est pas opaque
pour le gestionnaire de fond. Et si,
désolé, mais les fonds de fond et les
fonds de fonds à risque représentent une
part minime des actions sous gestion.
Les actifs nets au Luxembourg 82,18 %
dans les UCITS partie 1 qui publie tout.
État financier, rapport semiannuel et le
cas de D
simplifiées pour les investisseurs sont
très majoritairement actionnaires et
obligataires. C'est mentir que de dire
qu'un particulier peut seulement accéder
à des fonds à risque s'il n'est pas
qualifié. Entre parenthèses en gros
initié ou riche. Fermez la parenthèse.
Et même si c'est le cas, la société de
gestion n'investit pas au pif dans des
fonds au hasard.
Ah mais investit pas au pif là-dessus.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord. Elle
n'investit pas au pif. Après PWC et tout
et ces gens-là, c'est-à-dire des gens
qui ont été mis en cause dans le Lux, il
y a pas de souci. Euh concernant les
rescrits fiscaux. Et puis d'autre part,
cette personne qui n'est pas
technocrate, j'ai peut-être été un peu
virulent,
en tout cas enthousiaste. Enthousiaste,
pas virulent. Euh
moi je suis prêt à parler euh et
échanger avec elle euh pour voir euh
déjà voir qui est cette personne et qui
est capable de de voilà de de sortir.
On a on a dans notre communauté des gens
très spécialistes.
Ah non mais je dis pas je dis pas le
contraire mais euh en tout cas moi sur
les éléments que j'ai de fond
d'investissement et de d'investissement
de fond de fond euh je peux te dire que
c'est extrêmement opaque et c'est très
très préoccupant. Après qu'on me dise
tu trouves que c'est opaque ?
C'est opaque et c'est préoccupant. Tu
trouves que c'est opaque ?
Oui, je trouve que c'est opaque. Oui,
moi je je mais pas Feriew. Euh euh mais
euh
après effectivement que le système en
place dise "Vous inquiétez pas, on gère
le Grisbe. Il y a la la CPR qui est là,
il y a la MF qui est là." Oui, enfin je
veux dire effectivement tout le monde a
envie d'entendre que tout se passe bien
et que tout est bien géré, qu'il y a
plein de mots super techniques et
effectivement il y a tel pourcentage
effectivement Luxembourg etci ou ça ?
D'accord. N'empêche que tu as des
milliards qui passent qui sont issus de
l'assurance vie des Français dans les
paradis fiscaux à leur insu dans des
investissements dont ils n'ont pas
connaissance. Même si je suis d'accord
avec cette personne Vespasien, la
personne à la tête des des assurances,
c'est exactement
où va l'argent. Et pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle est pas capable de publier ça,
nous montrer au niveau de des structures
de GERS ? Où est le problème ? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? C'est des questions
basiques, non ?
Qu'est-ce que tu penses du secret des
affaires ? Ben, on voit déjà qui a créé
ce qui a à l'origine de enfin je veux
dire, on a déjà répondu à la question en
sachant qui a a créé cette loi.
Secret des affaires, c'est une façon
d'être opaque un peu plus. C'est
prétexter de dire que pour le business,
c'est bien d'être opaque parce qu'il y a
de la concurrence internationale. C'est
surtout bien, moi ce que je vois sur le
terrain, pour ne pas payer de
participation au salarié. C'est surtout
bien pour faire l'évasion fiscale et
c'est surtout bien pour ne pas répondre
aux syndicats, aux salariés et aux
associations de ou par l'argent ou par
le CICE
ou par tout cet argent là, tu vois. Donc
l'excuse et d'ailleurs c'est c'est ce
qui est marrant, c'est que ces gens qui
nous parlent de pseudopatriotisme
économique ne sont absolument pas, tu
vois. Donc parce que il considère que tu
vois, il faut protéger l'économie
française avec le secret des affaires.
Mais c'est pas être patriote que de que
de que de cacher ce qui se passe. Si tu
veux le fait de cacher un brevet, c'est
une chose mais le fait de ne pas vouloir
publier ses comptes ou de de dissimuler
ses ses comptes, çaen est une autre si
tu veux, en prétextant que la
concurrence après saurait ce qui se
passe et cetera. Tout ça c'est du prichy
précha de de voilà.
Est-ce que tu veux aborder un sujet
qu'on a pas abordé ?
Bah, j'aurais pu mais après ça serait
trop long là mais de parler des
investigations en cours où je vais
développer prochainement.
C'est pas trop.
OK. Euh donc Ah oui bah en fait la
troisème partie mais justement là c'est
pour faire d'honorable d'une certaine
façon. La troisème partie de la la
double investigation que je devais faire
de ça devait être trois trois parties et
la troisème partie c'était en fait sur
les cliniques privé. Ça va sortir aussi
dans un article écrit et là j'étais
agréablement surpris. Donc j'avais fait
l'enquête sur le groupe Vivalto, donc
qui a un groupe de clinique privée très
important en France qui est aussi des
épades et euh
et qui a aussi un moment de qui a aussi
une fois de plus, on a encore ce ce fond
qui est
comment dire d'Abou Dhabi qui qui est en
en minorité dans dans Investin dans
Vivalto enfin bref et j'avais vu qu'il y
avait des des remontées qu'il y avait
des en tout cas des flux financiers, je
dis pas des je dis pas des profits en
tout cas dire des flux financier qui
allait de Vivalto, des structures de
Vivalto
vers Luxembourg. Or, j'ai écrit un email
à au groupe et j'étais extrêmement
surpris. Le très rapidement, j'ai une
réponse de monsieur Daniel Kai qui est
le le le PDG et qui est aussi
administrateur parce qu'il y a plusieurs
sociétés en fait Vivalto et qui
qui m'a dit "Écoutez, j'ai bien reçu
votre mail, je vais répondre à toutes
vos questions." Il a répondu à toutes
mes questions au téléphone et je dis
"Vous pouvez me les mettre par email Il
m'a dit "Oui, bien sûr." Il m'a envoyé
un très long mail en répondant à toutes
mes questions. Alors euh moi je voilà,
c'est-à-dire là, je cherche je je soit
dire que je je l'investigation va sortir
euh
que je la sors parce que c'est juste
intéressant de savoir ce qui se passe
avec les groupes de cliniques privées si
tu veux, mais je dois vraiment
remercier, même si je suis pas forcément
d'accord avec les montages et cetera, je
dois vraiment remercier cette personne
pour la transparence.
Pour sa transparence. Euh
aussi, ça montre que même si moi j'ai un
j'ai un j'ai un biais, si tu veux, euh
bah je considère que quelqu'un qui ouvre
sa porte et qui dit "OK, je fais ça et
ça, mais vous pouvez voir ce que je
fais." Ben, j'ai forcément du respect
pour pour lui parce queil y a il y a un
échange qui est possible. Euh c'est ça
qui le plus important en fait, c'est
l'échange. C'est s'il y a pas d'échange
ou si la personne claque le en sortant
des trucs technocratiques ou en disant
"Non, vous inquiétez pas, on gère le
problème." Ça, tu peux être sûr que euh
je vais revenir derrière. Par contre, si
on m'ouvre la porte et qu'on me dit
"Voilà comment ça se passe" et qu'on
fait tout en détail, OK, pas de souci.
Et tu vas quand même vérifier.
Mais bien sûr, je vais tout vérifier,
c'est sûr. B oui, j'avais vérifié avant,
je revérifie derrière. Mais en tout cas,
j'apprécie la démarche pas au point au
niveau de l'ego, mais de dire qu'il y a
un échange qui est possible, tu vois.
C'est c'est ça le plus important pour
moi.
Alors, je t'ai posé une question et on
va te la reposer parce que on tu as pas
répondu. Dans quel pays sur cette
planète pouvons-nous vivre une justice
fiscale et vivre bien ?
Alors, justice fiscale, voyons voir. Euh
sûrement les pays du nord, je pense,
mais ça c'est voilà. Euh
après, j'en vois pas d'autres. Euh et
bien je considère que moi je je
changerai pas de pays pour tout l'ors du
monde euh malgré tout ce qui s'y passe.
et puis infiné même si on est dans un
pays qui n'est pas la France et je pense
là je reviens un peu à Marc Orel et à
toutes ces lectures où je quelque part
on est obligé dans la vie un peu notre
mission je pense en tant qu'être humain
c'est de justement de d'arriver à vivre
quel que soi les moments de joie de de
ou ou de tristesse ou ou les choses
qu'on va vivre nous en tant que humain
dans les années à venir on parlait de
crise financière sanitaire et
écologique. on est obligé de
après on peut dire appeler ça comme on
veut zen ou rester calme à l'intérieur.
Voilà. Donc ça quelque part quel que
soit le pays où on est, je veux dire il
y a que nous qui nous le donnons à
nous-même en fait. Donc il y a pas
besoin d'être d'un pays spécifique.
Trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Alors le premier ben en fait tout
simplement Marc Orel Solilock le dernier
que j'ai j'ai relu le la bande dessinée
de Inesler Lero Alguert qui est une amie
qui est une journaliste et lance
lanceuse d'alerte euh qui a fait une
enquête justement sur le monde de de
l'agroalimentaire
et et de la pollution en Bretagne de ce
que ça représente. C'est vraiment c'est
vraiment quelque chose à regarder. Je
vous conseille fortement de d'acheter
son sa BD et puis euh bon, on va faire
un peu de pub de de mon livre Là où est
l'argent édité chez
Ça ça ça se fait pas ça
ça se fait pas. Bon, excuse-moi. Bon,
alors pas mon livre alors
vas-y. C'est quoi ton livre ?
C'est là là où est l'argent. Voilà. Mais
sinon, j'en je mets j'en mets un autre
si tu veux si ça se fait pas.
Ouais. Bah oui.
OK. Excuse. Alors, un autre euh
un autre on va dire alors la
convivialité de de Ivan IC.
Bon, il y a GG qui repose une question,
on est obligé de la poser. Vas-y. Et
puis il y a quelqu'un qui dit qu'on
pioche toujours les questions des mêmes
personnes.
Donc, on va reposer une question pour
GG. Que pensent-il de l'arbitrage
international ? C'est un peu le même
problème que l'évasion fiscale, virgule
non, point d'interrogation.
Exactement.
De l'opacité pour cacher le déplacement
du pouvoir. Point d'interrogation.
Excellente question. Euh, j'ai un ami
qui est très intéressé par ce sujet. On
va essayer de de monter un peu un
travail de veille là-dessus. Euh mais
sans rentrer dans les détails, c'est
oui, c'est c'est un projet d'enquête
euh en tout cas d'investigation pour moi
qui est extrêmement intéressant, que je
je pense mener assez rapidement. C'est
en fait c'est de la justice parallèle
entre multinationales pour euh pour
gérer leur business entre eux. C'est
c'est vraiment un monde très opaque et
donc pour moi extrêmement intéressant
puisqu'il y a c'est un endroit où plein
où il y a plein de secrets.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Et tu sais comment ça se finit ? Un
conseil pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable ?
Bah je en fait je déjà au jeunes la
dernière fois j'avais conseillé l'amitié
quand j'étais venu. Là je dirais tout
simplement
de aux jeunes génération de se
questionner sur le réel désir de ce
qu'ils veulent faire en terme de de
travail ou de et et que ce désir soit
motivé
par le fait de servir les autres. enfin
je pense où la nature c'est pas
forcément des êtres humains, ça peut
être les animaux, la nature euh et que
d'accepter aussi de vivre dans
l'incertitude, même si c'est compliqué,
qu'on ne l'apprend pas à l'école et
qu'en étant capable de vivre avec
l'incertitude aussi, on s'ouvre vers de
la créativité et on trouve sa voix. Et
voilà. Donc je dirais en conseil euh le
désir, trouver le désir de ce qu'on veut
faire pour servir les les autres,
accepter l'incertitude
et puis apprendre aussi ce qu'on nous
apprend pas aussi à l'école à
à ne pas penser, à être tranquille
aussi, à ne rien faire parce qu'il faut
toujours faire plein de choses mais
aussi à ne rien faire.
C'est rendipité.
Oui.
Maxime Ren merci.
Merci à toi. Merci à vous.
[Musique]